this is jaco podcast number 81 with echo
Charles and me
Jaco Wellington good evening echo good
evening November 29 1915 it has teamed
the trenches are ankle-deep some places
calf deep in mud and the communications
trenches are rushing streams of brown
water the manner wet through but to
stick the job like Britons and I hope
for their sake that the weather lifts
with the morning the guns have been
strafing today though up till now we
have dodged the show it may be ours
again tomorrow though one never knows
this is from the diary of Captain
Charlie may the British Army officer
commander of B Company 22nd manchester
pals battalion of the manchester
regiment who served in world war one he
was married to Bessie Mae then they had
one daughter who was born July 20th 1914
so she was a little over a year old when
this journal was being written from the
trenches
then it continues December 1st 1915 it
is exciting work sniping in fact one
must curb the tendency lest it should
become a fascination the second in
command of the Elance the East
Lanchester regimen and myself put in a
couple hours this morning and had quite
a bit of fun worrying the Boches in
their trenches one fellow was walking
across the open 2,000 yards off when I
spotted him and let go you never saw a
chap move quicker in your life he ran
for a tree and jumped behind it and I
let him have four more there whether I
got him or not I don't know but he
didn't move for the next half hour I
know because I waited so anxiously for
him last night or rather 1:30 this
morning I got outside the barbed wire
and got lost three times I had to fling
myself down in the wet grass bury my
nose in it and grovel while the machine
guns went chattering over me it is
remarkable with what speed one learns to
adopt the prone position January 13th
1916 I long and long to see you to clasp
you in my arms and I long with all my
heart to see my baby how I love her what
hopes I have for her what a sweet girl
she will make February 25th 1916 woke up
this morning to find the snow pelting
down and covering the ground fully five
inches deep also it was freezing hard
cotton a fellow officer came in to
breakfast with us
he brought the little Bible which
another soldier had taken from the body
of a dead German on the Flyleaf in a
child's handwriting the word dad at war
is very sad perhaps the man may have
done and been something too loathes and
detests I do not know all I am conscious
of is that somewhere in his fatherland
there is a little child who called him
daddy April 6 1916 Fritz strafed our new
trenches with heavies and search round
the support with HG shrapnel and other
such obnoxious stuff one shell claimed
three NCOs and wounded three men we all
feel wild to get at the beasts and I
hope we may string him up on the wire I
saw the killed go down the line it was a
pitiful sight poor boys shell fire is a
horrid thing breasty a lad who is a
sergeant of mine was the worse his body
full of gaping holes it was very very
sad do those at home realize how their
boys go out for them never can they do
enough for their soldiers never can they
repay the debt they owe not that the men
ask any reward
but one day we'll get Adam with the
bayonet we'll take our price then for
gret Z and all the other hundreds
thousands gret Z slain as they were
standing at their posts
June 17th 1916 I do not want to die the
thought that I may never see you or our
darling baby again turns my bowels to
water my conscience is clear that I have
always tried to make life a joy for you
but it is the thought that our babe may
grow up without my knowing her and
without her knowing me I pray God I may
do my duty for I know whatever that may
entail you would not have it otherwise
June 23rd 1916 everything is speeding up
to no end
ammunition by the hundred wagon load is
pouring up it should certainly not be
for lack of ammunition if we do not make
a huge success of the venture yet one
cannot help feeling a little anxious and
worried so much depends on this great
throw and what he's talking about there
in this part of the journal it reflects
the build-up for the Battle of the Somme
and although Charlie doesn't know
exactly when the battle is going to
commence
they're obviously only distributing that
information with people that have the
need to know they know that a major
attack is forthcoming and that's why
they've got all that ammunition piled up
more than they could ever think they
could possibly need back to the journal
June 28 1916 the moment seems very
auspicious for us to strike perhaps we
will on Friday
July 1st 1916 we marched up to the
assembly trench last night the most
exciting March imaginable guns all
around crashed and roared till sometimes
it was quite impossible to hear oneself
speak it was however a fine sight and
one realized from it what gun power
really means fritz
of course strafed back and reply causing
us some uneasiness and a few casualties
before we even reached the line the
night passed noisily and with a few more
casualties the Hun puts a barrage on us
every now and then and generally claims
one or two victims it is a glorious
morning we go over in two hours time it
seems a long time to wait and I think
whatever happens we shall all feel
relieved once the line is launched no
man's land is a tangled desert
unless one could see it one cannot
imagine what a terrible state of
disorder it is in but we do not yet seem
to have stopped the machine guns these
are popping off all along our parapet as
I write I trust they will not claim to
many of our lads before the day is over
now I close this old diary down for the
next few days since I may not take it in
to the line I will keep a record of how
things go and enter it up later
well
that update never took place
then Charlie may was wrong about how
many British soldiers would be claimed
before the day was over he didn't think
it would claim too many but as you know
the first day of the battle was on July
1st turned out to be the worst day in
history for the British Army and they
suffered almost 60,000 casualties 60,000
casualties in one day and like I said
those casualties included Charlie May
who went over the top on July 1st under
the cover of Allied artillery he was
leading B Company and he and his men
fought their way across no-man's land
and just as they reached German lines
Charlie was a hit by shellfire then
killed and his diary was found by the
man that eventually dragged him back to
the trenches private arthur bunting who
mailed the diary to Charlie's wife Maude
now
the British have a steep military
history and obviously this is the
kingdom that we Americans rebelled
against in the Revolutionary War and we
fought them again in the war of 1812 and
we actually had a bunch of other little
various disputes with them until the
late 1800s when during something called
the great reproach 'men through various
forces in the world
our political objectives were aligned
and we became the staunchest of allies
with Great Britain through World War one
and World War two and Korea and Vietnam
and even up till now in Iraq and
Afghanistan and I've been lucky enough
to work alongside Brits on just a couple
occasions while I was in the military
and there's no doubt that they are just
outstanding troops professional in
everything that they do and they leave
that impression on you you can actually
feel the pride of their military
tradition and tonight wanted to take a
look at a book that is part of that
military tradition and the book is
called serve to lead
and I'm going to start with some
statements from the introduction to this
version of the book and the version of
the book that I'm reading is the old
version I think it's from 1954 57
originally written right after World War
2 and these comments here are from a guy
named Robin Matthews a former British
Army officer graduate of the Royal
Military Academy of Sandhurst that's
like the British West Point he went on
to command his regiment the light
dragoons which included a tour of duty
in Iraq in 2005 he also served with 16
Air Assault Brigade in Helmand province
in Afghanistan and here's what he has to
say about this book served to lead is a
remarkable book produced by the Royal
Military Academy Sandhurst after the
Second World War it is as clear and
concise the treatise on leadership as
you will find it also provides a
fascinating glimpse into what sets the
profession of arms apart from any other
served to lead is synonymous with
Sandhurst placed on the bed of every
officer cadet at the beginning of the
military training somewhere between
prayer-book which is what I thought it
was initially and Bible as it has often
been referred it lays out what is
expected and what to expect
unequivocally it establishes
selflessness self disciplined integrity
and duty as the bedrock of leadership
excitingly it speaks of courage and
boldness as the essential
differentiators upon which events turn
and to which soldiers and leaders are
instinctively drawn there is so much to
enjoy and consider on every page but the
most beguiling message of the book
concerns humility leadership must
confident but unless it is matched in
equal measure by humility it jars at
which point the lead simply fall away if
I am to lead you first and foremost I
must be your servant like any good book
the clue is in the title in this case
simple seemingly contradictory but
ultimately profound serve to lead and
that's the intro to this book and
obviously there's a dichotomy of
leadership he's already talking about
things that we talk about all the time
and yes you've got to be confident but
you've got to be humble and the title
the book is a contradictory is a
dichotomy in its own sense right serve
to lead and like I said this book they
actually have a new one and I have the
new one I went with the old one and the
reason I wanted the old one there's a
couple things that we're going to prom
to point out that clearly they've
changed their faults on and maybe we'll
end up doing a compare and contrast with
the new one there aren't that many
differences but there certainly are some
very significant different differences
and we'll get to those and this is going
to kick off with a piece from the Lord
Bishop of Durham it is the fact that
some men possess an inbred superiority
which gives them a dominating influence
over their contemporaries and marks them
out unmistakeably for leadership this
phenomenon is as certain as it is
mysterious it is apparent in every
Association of human beings in every
variety of circumstances and on every
plane of culture in a school among boys
in a College among the students in a
factory shipyard or mine among the
workmen as certainly as in the church
and in the nation there are those who
with an assured and unquestioned title
take the leading place and shape the
general conduct so there's an opinion
people ask all the time are leaders born
or made
that one right there is
leaders are born and that's I I always
say both I always say there's there's
certain leadership qualities that people
are born with and some people are born
with a lot of them some people are
vulnerable all of those qualities some
people are born with a lot less some
people aren't born of any they're not
going to be much of a leader it doesn't
matter how much you train them you can
get them better but they're not going to
be a great leader and obviously some
some leaders don't need much training
there's very few of those leaders that
just don't they just get it out of the
gate as just born that way I think it's
a mixture of both and I think you're
born with some leadership capability and
the more you hone it the more you work
on it the better you're going to be why
would you think or why do you think that
is because to be a leader like the good
strong qualities that you gotta have are
so contradict or counterintuitive
they're not even counterintuitive but
you can get better at all of them you
know a couple the one that's for
instance some people are naturally
talented or some people are naturally
articulate people so they're able to get
their message across in simple clear
concise language that's it very
important now if you're born with that
you're lucky
right good job you were born with that
you were born an articulate person if
you weren't guess what you can have to
work at it you have to read you have to
write you have to listen you have to
practice speaking to people and you will
get better at it so those that's your
example some people just have it
naturally and but even people that have
it naturally will get better at it over
time I was always pretty comfortable
speaking to people but obviously when I
was in the military I spoke to people
all the time and when I was in a
training training situation as a young
enlisted seal I was put up in front of
classroom to speak to people and I got
better at it and then when I became an
officer and a leader now I was briefing
people and so I'm doing it even more and
then I took over the training for the
West Coast seals and now I was briefing
people all the time and when I was
overseas I was briefing you know
Colonels and Generals and okay you're
gonna brief a bunch of times you're
going to get better at it
I was already ok at it
naturally but I got better at it and I'm
still getting better at it today so
that's the same with any of these
particular talents you know being able
to simplify things being able to detach
those are all important leadership
qualities you can have a certain level
that you're capable at but the more you
practice them the better off you're
gonna be yeah yes so it's a combination
yeah so how you say like Ola there's
it's pretty rare that you get somebody
who's um has all the qualities right out
of the gate yeah nothing I can't I've
never met anybody that just just
dominated and right a Greek uh lady like
detaching for example that's not that's
kind of counter to your natural wave
yeah that's true most people are going
to want to get in there yeah
now I I just thought this example I've
talked about him a little bit on the on
the podcast where we had to embarrass on
ultimately grizzard he was uh he was the
use my system platoon commander when I
was at SEAL team one and he got murdered
it was horrible tragic situation he was
involved in a murder suicide and but he
had a lot of those capabilities he had a
lot of he was a very articulate he was a
quarterback at the Navy football team we
had like a real good presence to him he
spoke clearly he was down to earth and
yet you know very he could elevate
himself very quickly when he's talking
to the cert you know if he needed to
elevate himself he just had a lot of
those qualities very naturally and and
guess what he was at the Naval Academy
he played football
he was constantly getting in front of
his you know getting in the huddle and
telling guys what was gonna happen and
you get good at that over time and part
of that is so I don't know how much of
it you know I didn't know when he was a
football player when he was in eighth
grade maybe he was stammering and trying
to put his thoughts together but then he
trained it over and over and over again
he got better at it and maybe by the
time he got to me as a 23 year old
lieutenant j.g he was like oh we gonna
get in a huddle I'll tell you guys
what's going on and so you know even
though it appeared to me like it was
natural probably wasn't it was probably
trained you know he had some natural
capability but he played football his
whole life and that was that yes so in a
way you can kind of in this
maybe kinda interchangeable as far as
the expression but you know you say
natural capability it could be that they
gain it through learning or whatever
just through their environment
you know like as a kid you know yeah
yeah so playing football and then
they'll bring it to the training
situation and they like so yeah but I
think it's got to be a little bit of
both right yeah yeah and you will get
better at it but the more you focus on
that particular skill like some people
are very comfortable talking in you know
even they're not even comfortable
talking in a conversation right oh yeah
and so if you end up with a kid like
that well you got to get them out with
socialize them and get him in get him in
front of people talking all the time and
that will be good for them yeah if you
have someone that's if you've got a kid
or yeah if you got a kid or a young
leader that doesn't know when to shut up
right how are you gonna because
sometimes leaders are like that too they
want to hear themselves talk and they
just keep talking all the time and guess
what the more you talk the less people
listen so if I'm giving orders on every
little thing that we've gotten to do in
front of us eventually you're not
listening to me anymore and when
something critical comes up you're still
not listening to me because I've been
talking for the past six straight months
won't shut my piehole so that's a bad
situation so how do we get that person
to quiet down it's both yeah
all right so now we're going to hear
from a guy named Field Marshal William
slam I think bill slam is what they
ended up calling him he was in World War
one and World War two wounded multiple
times I think three times led the 14th
army in Burma World War two and he also
fought with the Anzac so the the
Australian New Zealand Army Corps at
Gallipoli so you could say he's got a
pretty good view of things sure so he
this believe it or not the first this
this book kicks off with talking about
morale and the morale of the troops so
here we go back to the book morale was a
state of mind it is that intangible
force which will move a whole group of
men to give their last ounce to achieve
some
without counting the cost to themselves
that makes them feel that they are part
of something greater than themselves now
this is interesting so so he's talking
about the importance of morale now going
back to the subject we were just talking
about back to the book I learned to that
one did not need to be an orator to be
effective two things only were necessary
first to know what you were talking
about and second and most important to
believe it yourself so there you go you
don't need to be great orator but you've
got to know what you're talking about
and you got to believe it yeah those are
two really good places to start he
continues on talking about morality he
says a most potent factor in spreading
this belief in the efficiency of an
organization is a sense of discipline we
tried to make our discipline intelligent
but we were old-fashioned army and we
insisted on outward signs we expected
soldiers to salute and officers to
salute in return both in mutual
confidence and respect I encouraged all
officers to insist whenever possible and
there were a few places where it was not
possible on good turnout and personal
cleanliness it takes courage especially
for a young officer to check a man met
on the road for not properly saluting or
for slovenly appearance but every time
he does it adds to his stock of moral
courage and whatever the soldier may say
he has respect for the officer who does
pull him up now this is an interesting
point right because what we're talking
about here is all I see echoes you know
not wearing his uniform correctly so I'm
going to go over and tighten you up that
is you can see where you can see where
people are probably thinking yeah jock
will be all over that guy right
no actually wrong that's actually wrong
and what I want to talk about here is
I'm gonna talk about what I call the
leadership capital you only have some
leadership capital in your bank and
you've got to decide what as a leader
you're going to spend that capital on
and if I see you out of uniform or
you're looking sloppy I've got to decide
if it's worth me investing my leadership
capital and going over and telling you
that you need to tighten it up hey echo
you get that hey sergeant Charles you
need to get your uniform squared away
you look like crap you're setting a bad
example is that what I want to invest my
leadership capital on now Kennedy
sometimes yes absolutely and we've
talked about the many cases where that
occurs you know when you look at at
Hackworth when hack boards showed up to
vietnam as a battalion commander he
tightened up their uniform standards
immediately mmm he tightened him up
immediately he knew he needed to invest
that leadership capital he needed to
start with the small things but if
you're in a garrison situation and you
see somebody that maybe isn't doing
there isn't wearing their uniform
properly and you decide you're going to
go tighten them up I'm not saying it's
the wrong answer and as lace Pavan will
tell you it's not what you preach is
what you tolerate and so if you tolerate
the guys looking like crap they're just
going to continue going down that hill
of looking like crap now to me there's a
certain point right that I won't let you
go past if you're a little out of the
out of the standard maybe I'm going to
let that one slide a little bit right
but once you get to a point where you're
looking like crap well guess what I am
absolutely going to tighten you up and
I'm going to explain to you why it's
important look I'm not going to go and
yell at you no not happening
so you've got to be careful how you
ration your your discipline and your
leadership capital right if you just run
around yelling at everyone or getting in
everyone's face for every little thing
that they're doing pretty soon you could
look at that like well pretty soon
they'll let that they'll be scared of
making a mistake but that's that's the
point now you got people that are scared
to make a mistake yeah now you're
cutting off their abilities and their
desire to think freely so the bottom
line with this balance you've got to
stay balanced in these things and don't
waste your leadership capitals talking
to a guy the other day he was running a
off site for his executive team and I
talked to him and and he said man you
know it was just junk I said what
happened and he had showed up the
executive off-site and he's in the
company and he's the guy that's running
the off-site and he gets there and he
says all right guys not while we're here
no cell phones so everyone put your cell
phones away we need to focus it's a
strategic meeting we need to we need to
get this done so the guys put their cell
phones away and they start the meeting
he says five minutes into the meeting
the CEO breaks out a cell phone starts
looking at it a minute after everyone
sees that you got half the room looking
at their cell phone so yeah and he went
like got kind of nuts on him you know
this is man what's what's going on and
people aren't even paying attention
after the first at first hour he's just
you know what's going on and I said to
him I said bro let's look at what you
just so then he said then he lost them
like the the meeting just went downhill
yeah and I said to him let's talk about
what you did because you invested your
leadership capital for this important
meeting on telling people to not use
their cell phones did you tell them why
he's like not really did you explain to
them when they would be able to use
their cell phones no I didn't so you
just wait now this company is a
financial company they've got a lot of
things going on you can imagine the CEO
the big financial companies got a lot of
important calls and emails to check and
all that and all of a sudden gets told
no cell phone what is that going to end
mmm what important thing is happening at
my company today where I'm not allowed
to talk on my cell phone and answer
emails or look at look at my emails and
I'm the guy so so when am I supposed to
when would I be able to look at you
didn't tell me that so he invested all
of his leadership capital to get people
to do no cell phones and he spent it and
there wasn't any left and and the you
know so you have to be careful now you
have to approach it the right way right
first of all you could say hey listen
guys we're going to power through a
solid hour right now
I'm gonna ask you unless it's just
critical keep your cell phones put away
and let's power through this let's get
some good conversation going right and
in an hour we're going to take a
20-minute break where you can catch up
when you got to catch up on and then
we'll do another hour after that so now
people understand what's happening and
they understand why and by the way you
know if everyone's on their cell phones
we're not going to get what we need out
of this meeting so you gotta explain and
you don't want to invest your leadership
capital on things that don't matter
so if you're the senior guy in a
leadership position and you're focused
on some little person that's out of
uniform and that's what your focus is
that's that's not a good focus to have
right you should set the standard and
your subordinate leadership all the way
down to the front where you've got like
you and me are peers and I don't let you
I'm the one not I'm not waiting for the
boss to come by and tighten up uniform I
won't let you tighten up I won't let you
wear a crappy looking uniform that's
what I want I want to have a gang
mentality where we're self policing
because the minute on from the top doing
that again does this happen sometimes
yes I'm not setting out a black and
white rule here I'm giving the broad
guidance that if your Hackworth and
you're taking over a battalion where
people's lives are at risk sand you know
that there's slack everywhere and
they're not doing a good job you got to
go in there and tighten them up and one
of the best ways to do that is go in
there and start on the small things but
if you've got a functioning unit that
there's nothing critical happening and
you're trying to build that team into
something that's that's a winning team
and the first thing you could do is go
in and focus on some of these small
things when you haven't really
established yourself that could be
problematic so think about those things
when you're in those positions
all right going back to the book I do
not say that the men of the fourteenth
army welcome to difficulties but they
grew to take fierce pride in overcoming
them by determination and ingenuity from
start to finish they had only two items
of equipment that were never in short
supply their brains and their courage
they lived up to the unofficial motto I
gave them god helps those who help
themselves
and once again that's the same thing
that Colonel Bill leader said god help
yourselves alright now we're going to
move on to still still talking about
morale we're gonna talk to only hear
from Field Marshal Bernard Montgomery if
you don't know who that is Monty World
War one the anglo-irish war the
Palestine conflicts that disbar
uprisings and World War two he you know
obviously ran the British Eighth Army
for war - so we've once again we've got
a person with some very solid
perspective on leadership and combat
leadership the quality of morale back to
the book in war the moral stature of
some men increases and their characters
grow stronger and more closely knit in
proportion to the discomforts and
dangers they are called upon to face
boom so some guys get better some guys
rise to the occasion
back to the book such men will
occasionally perform in battle
remarkable acts of selfless courage and
daring and will endure with the
extraordinary fortitude and patience the
burdens thrust upon them
other men however will under the stress
of hardships or dangers surrender to
fear or fatigue and allow their
characters to disintegrate this
disintegration will usually take the
form of loosening of the moral fiber
which results in timidity of action and
flatness and appearance while those who
have gone to seed will be dirty
and their appearance will be sluggish
and will be slovenly in the later cases
there has been a general loosening of
character due to partial surrender to
fear so I totally agree with this you
see in combat situations people either
get better or they get worse
some people just kind of cruise right
stay in that same zone but but some
people they get better they get worse
they rise to the occasion or they fall
back to look the good soldier
the man with high morale has not
surrendered to fear and has maintained
his personal standards the bad soldier
the man with low morale has become
incapable of independent action and has
to some extent shed a part of his human
individuality that's an interesting
that's an interesting statement that the
person that's incapable of innovate of
independent action he said he shed some
of his human individuality back to the
book basic factors of morale we now must
consider the factors Conte what what
factors constitute morale of the soldier
in the heat of battle certain factors
may be described as essential conditions
without which high morale cannot exist
these four basic factors are one
leadership to discipline three
comradeship and four self-respect a
fifth factor devotion to cause must
exist but need not necessarily influence
all the soldiers finally there are
numerous contributory factors which are
great importance but are not essential
conditions starting with this first one
leadership morale is in the first place
based on leadership good morale is
impossible without good leaders human
beings are fundamentally alike in that
certain common characteristics apply to
all men in varying degrees in battle the
most important of these characteristics
is fear
all men are afraid at one time or
another to a greater or lesser extent in
moments of fear they band together and
look for guidance they seek for a person
to give decisions they look for a leader
the leaders power of decision results
from his ability to remain calm in the
crisis his greatest asset is the ability
to act normally in abnormal conditions
to continue to think rationally when his
men have ceased to think to be decisive
in action when they are paralyzed by
fear a little bit of normal face from
Monti act normally in abnormal
conditions remain calm
back to the book the object of training
must be first to select those who
possess them within them the
potentialities of leadership and
secondly to develop these potentialities
this is accomplished by giving the
leader responsibility the leaders
character will develop in proportion to
the responsibilities with which he has
been entrusted so there you go he's
saying the same thing that we were
talking about earlier you have certain
potentials and you got to develop those
and how do you develop them with people
you give people you want to develop
leaders you give them responsibilities
you don't give them responsibility
that's going to kill them but you give
them responsibility that's going to
definitely test them and they're going
to have to step up to be able to perform
back to the book the two vital
attributes of a leader are a decision in
action and B calmness in crisis given
these two attributes a key will succeed
without them he will fail our great
problem in peace is to select leaders
it's to select as leaders men whose
brain will remain clear when intensely
frightened
so from Monty you got to remain calm hmm
now he's going to talk about discipline
the object of discipline is the conquest
of fear there are two aspects of fear
fear can suddenly attack a man through
his imagination a corpse in a ditch or a
grave by the far side of the road will
remind him of his position he will
suddenly realize that he himself is
liable to be killed it is a function of
discipline to fortify the mind so that
it becomes reconciled to unpleasant
sights and accepts them as normal
everyday occurrences fear can also creep
upon a man during periods of monotony on
the line at such time he will have the
opportunity to appreciate the dangers
which beset his life fear acting through
his thoughts can so reduce the man's
hard core of courage that he will become
nervous and fearful discipline
strengthens the minds that it becomes
impervious to the corroding influence of
fear it teaches men to confine their
thought within certain definite limits
it instills the habit of self-control
that's pretty amazing it's pretty
amazing
assessment to think that the one of the
best premiere tools to overcome fears
discipline
back to the book discipline implies a
conception of duty nothing will be
accomplished in the crisis by the man
without a sense of duty
makes sense now he's going to talk about
comradeship back to look morale can not
be good unless men come to have
affection for each other
a fellow feeling must grow up which will
result in a spirit of comradeship an
army is made of human beings so that
however much leader may inspire as men
however perfect the discipline the
morale will be hard and unsympathetic if
the warmth of comradeship has not been
added oh yeah you got to be got to be
the hardcore disciplinarian but you need
the warmth of comradeship
back to the book war though a hard
business is not necessarily a grim one
men must laugh and joke together must
enjoy each other's company company and
must get fun out of even life I must get
fun out of life even in times of danger
so do you want to have a good time yes
you do and the the thing that makes
these dangerous times more bearable is
when you're having fun during them and
that's one of the things I don't talk a
whole lot about the SEAL training in
here on the podcast but one of the
things that you do in SEAL training is
you're doing miserable things called wet
tired and you're having fun the whole
time you're learning that hey guess what
I can sit here and be cold and it's
miserable or I can be cold and I can
laugh about it and I can make fun of my
friend the way he's shivering and you
know that's what makes it bearable and
the same thing happens when you get
overseas and you joke about really dark
things you know dark sense of humor that
comes out real strong when you're
overseas I think yeah one of my one of
my buddies who is super paranoid I've
talked about him on here before the guys
the guys found a tube that had shipped
like maps or something and if you pulled
the tube apart real fast it sounded like
a mortar launch right so they'd get
outside his tent and he was super
paranoid we spent a little bit of time
getting mortared and so he was a little
on edge from that yeah so they'd go
outside of his tent you know and you can
hear through the tent it's just a little
piece of fabric and they go outside his
tent and they pull that thing and it
would sound like a mortar tube they did
hear he freaked so what are the cross
doing here or you know at first you hear
him like fall and likes to hit the
ground and then you'd hear the giggling
of the guys outside and then you hear
him Costin everyone out yeah but yeah
but it was fun it was funny too far a
little too far maybe but but everyone's
having a good time and even him you know
we'd get done and he would become
outside you guys are bastards and we'd
laugh about it that's the kind of thing
where you're you gotta have fun in these
tough situations II
yeah yeah that makes sense that's
probably why you know like nowadays like
contemporary companies they in court
like Jayde's company Frank mob they got
foosball yeah ping pong I heard I heard
massive noises the other day Nelson kind
of sounded like like a mortar fire
nothing quite mortar fire but there was
something I didn't know what it was and
they were they were in a in a nerf gun
fire fire yeah yeah and by the way it
was sloppy like they would develop takes
me yeah there was no cover and move
happening is just oh every man for
himself I was that disappointed
yeah but the third but they're having
like the reason right where it's it I
mean these are did I mean conceptually
it's the same thing obviously you know
it's way different no actually it's way
different but it's not actually not all
through tough things in a business in a
company have fun with it and when I work
with companies that are good good
companies and they're going through
something tough the ones that have good
morale the ones that are laughing
they're the ones that do better
yes who wants to go to work yeah if you
don't enjoy the people yet with you know
yeah like why would you want to do that
you know one of the one of the I hate
you can call it the worst job but I was
the animals age right so every day I'm
wearing a uniform I'm in sitting in a
desk all day I did it for 13 months it
was just that part of it it's it's you
know even is just a miserable job right
luckily first of all the Admiral is a
great guy and I had a lot we know we
joked around all the time with him and
his executive assistant is a guy that I
would literally not I would go two or
three weeks at a time and we wouldn't
say one serious thing to each other
everything would be some joke about
every all the misery that we were going
through and by misery I just mean you
know hours worth of meetings and
traveling all the time and his being on
the road and staying in crappy hotels
and flights getting you know bumped and
canceled and being held over and the
Admirals suitcase not showing up
somewhere and he's supposed to go on
stage it doesn't have a uniform with him
and like that's you know not fun guess
what I had fun the whole time and we'd
be joking about
I'd say well I guess I'm going to get to
take one again for the team which is
laughing yeah so yeah even in these
situations that aren't fun have you got
to have fun with them and that
definitely will help out your round if
you're a leadership position and all you
do is just bare you get get drown in the
misery that you're going through every
single person that's with you is going
to be going through the same thing and
so as a leader you got a vessel once
again going back to the dichotomy of
leadership you got a you got a no-win
okay the guys are too much stress
they're not having fun I need to have
fun I need to start a nerf war in the in
the office here so guys loosen up and
then there's times where hey guys are
having too much fun we got to type them
up yeah yeah like hey guys we got this
to do and so you got to ride that that
line and balance it out correctly yeah
yeah the cool huh um like newer
companies that were companies nowadays
they are incorporating that element into
the the actual color you know yakking
about yes you're right
and there's companies nowadays that do
it too much and all of a sudden I can't
get anything done yeah they're missing
area because everyone's playing ping
pong right everyone's in the Lego room
yeah they got rooms now is that go you
go there and sink right he'll play with
Legos because that relaxes your mind I
guess not me when I'm around Legos I
think I want to step on them cuz I got
kids throw Z up don't let Legos is a
nightmare so I don't like being around
Legos I got the PTSD from Lego stepping
when I was at my kids were younger label
you know cuz you can't ever get your son
enough Legos apparently correct because
they just need everything and when I was
a kid there was not that many different
types of Legos you had blocks right long
ones and shorter ones yeah
nowadays you get Legos but they have
hands and boards and machine guns and
they got cool stuff but bain't Legos
anymore they're little toys
they'll come with the little Legos and
they still hurt the Box step on they are
surprisingly sharp for kids made your
choice you know yeah major sharp all
right going back to the book is the
other thing you talk about self respect
no man can be said to possess high
morale if the quality of self respect is
lacking and this is something that dick
winters talked about through that self
respecting and how that drove him
soldiers must be encouraged to
respect themselves at all times and
under all conditions self-respect
implies a determination to maintain
personal standards of behavior a man who
respects himself will allow neither
himself to become slovenly nor his
quarters dirty even in action he will
take care to see that his personal
appearance suffers as little as possible
it is the job of the noncommissioned
officer to maintain this aspect of
discipline it is the function of the
officer to encourage and dis instill
self-respect so interesting he breaks
that down a little bit like I was
talking about if I'm the senior guy and
I'm around yelling at people about how
they're looking that's not good that
should be my subordinate leadership
should be tightening that stuff up okay
here's this conclusion again this is
Monte talking in brief high morale has
been defined as the quality which makes
men endure and show courage in times of
fatigue and danger the cultivation of
morale depends on the training of
leaders an inculcation of discipline the
encouragement of comradeship and the
infusing of self-respect the leaders
must have a belief in their cause and
they must pay attention to numerous
contributory factors of considerable but
secondary importance we live today in a
scientific age but we soldiers have to
remember that the raw material in which
we have to deal is men man is still the
first weapon of war his training is the
most important consideration in
fashioning of a fighting army all modern
science is directed towards his
assistants but on his efforts depends
the outcome of the battle the morale of
the soldier is the most important single
factor in war
so there's Monty and that's that can be
said for just about any organization
what your organization is made up of
people and you know you hear that with
businesses all the time and our people
our most important assets that's
generally going to be the case here's
some now we get into the leadership the
actual leadership section interesting
again they start off with morale that's
the first chapter now they move into
leadership and you know clearly from
what he just said morale is the most
important thing in winning battle I
don't agree I think leadership is the
most important thing now is number one
is number one factor in good morale is
leadership so I guess you know you could
see where we're coming from a different
angle but my thought is a little bit
different my thought is the most
important thing is leadership and I
think that leadership covers other
things just be besides the morale of the
men because now we're talking about the
strategy that you're using the tactic
that you use and everything is covered
by leadership including morale yeah so
yeah they're looking at it from up not
opposite but just varying perspectives
when he thinks leadership is part of
morale you think around eyebrows are the
leadership yes I think you have
identified the situation correctly all
right here some more from Monty on
leadership I would define leadership as
the will to dominate together with the
character which inspires confidence a
leader has got to learn to dominate the
events which surround him you must never
allow these events to get the better of
him he must allow nothing to divert him
from his aim he must always be on top of
his job and be prepared to accept
responsibility so Monty's talking about
ownership now what I have to caveat this
with is you get these people that are
single-minded right and that they're
going to dominate everything that's
going on around them and they do that
from a tactical perspective not from a
strategic perspective so for instance if
you say I must never or I must dominate
the events which surround me
and must allow nothing to divert me from
my aim that can actually be problematic
if it doesn't make strategic sense right
so if I'm always worried about
dominating everything that's going on
around me and the thing that's going on
around me isn't really that important
I'm wasting my time on it so this has to
this has to be sort of offset a little
bit by that dichotomy of leadership
which is yes you want to dominate what's
going on but if what's going on is
important you need to let it go you need
to just let it go a little bit all right
so now we're going to hear from Jeb and
by the way this book what this book
served to lead it's it's basically a
bunch I said have said this in the
beginning but it's it's a bunch of small
excerpts bigger than quotes some of them
are just quotes which I don't do a bunch
of like ages reading quotes I do a
couple I'm going to do a couple today
but some of them are like you know two
three four pages of people's views on
leadership of which I'm pulling out some
of the highlights and interestingly for
the first time I was going through some
of this and I was like you know what I'm
actually it was something that I did
something that I've said a million times
and so I said you know what I'm not
actually gonna highlight this again
because I've said it over and over again
now clearly with discipline I just
talked about it for 47 minutes and I
probably always will when I get the
opportunity but there's a lot more about
this but as all section on discipline
we'll get to all right
now we're going to talk over here from
the general john hackett again world war
two half can campaign it's part of
Market Garden which is the big airborne
operation world war two that here's what
he says I am a soldier in speaking of
leadership I do so as a soldier and when
I think about it as any soldier often
must I do so in the context of battle
pressures in battle are high and in
battle as a consequence the problems of
leadership stand out in bold relief and
that's something very similar which what
I say which is
combat is like life amplified and
intensified wrote that an extreme
ownership and that's what I'm talking
about and because it's that way it's
very easy to identify what's going on
with the leadership it's very the
problems of leadership stand out in bold
relief
you said it better than me back to the
book but while battle may be unique the
problems that it exposes are not right
yes leadership problems that have been
working for seven years with other
companies and people that are not going
to battle and guess what the problem is
that battle exposes are not unique to
battle for leadership is concerned with
getting people to do things and is most
keenly needed when difficulties doubts
and dangers are at their greatest in
whatever sphere this is attempted the
problems are essentially similar so
anytime you've got a team you got trying
to make them do something the problems
are pretty much going to be similar back
to look I said that leadership was
concerned with getting people to do
things what I meant was getting them to
do things willingly so we don't want to
just bark orders of people that doesn't
work doesn't work in business doesn't
work on the battlefield we'll work for
five minutes yes it will
well I can I yell at you and get you to
do something yep sure you're on
monster.com looking for a new job and
you know back to the book a man really
only gets a full response from the men
he leads by something approaching the
complete fusion of his own identity with
the hole that he and they together form
so think about that if you're in charge
of something and you're a leader you
need to become that thing you need to
become that team you need to become that
goal mm I like that one and you can see
when people get possessed like you look
at the modern business leaders today
those are people that you know Steve
Jobs use the concept with the product
the he was Apple and that's one of those
things that was so beneficial hmm Elon
Musk just like he is what he's trying to
do yeah back to the book successful
military leadership is impossible
without the leaders total engagement in
the task in hand and to the group
committed to his care for its discharge
and what's interesting about that talk
to your brother Jake Charles I'm not too
long ago actually it was pretty long ago
and he and he said something to me and
it was like a big revelation to him and
he was very is a very he had a good way
of saying what I'm just reading about
right now we were talking about
something he was going to a meeting and
he was going to be you know talking
about something there was some
controversy about whether we're gonna go
and and he said that the person that
cares the most wins and that's a great
statement it's very true is not a
hundred percent true did the percentage
is very high up there because if I just
care about something so much and I'm
gonna drive with it further than you if
I care about this decision more than you
do yeah I got a really good chance of
winning yeah really good chance of
winning yeah it kind of seems like that
translates into any goal yeah I mean the
more you care about it the more
probability yeah I guess the only really
only place where it becomes problematic
is if I I care about something you know
at 97 level 97 and you care about with a
opposite decision you're also at level
97 another thing is now we got an issue
now we got a problem
because we're both going to think we're
gonna win and we both believe that we
need to win again how does it run in the
distant now we got an ego scenario going
on and things become problematic and you
know to where this just becomes stupid
is in the when you hear people having
political I would use an air quotes on
that one political debates around
something yeah you know this person
totally believes 100% and this person
totally cares a hundred percent and
they're going to go nuts on each other
and they don't listen to anything that
the other person says and you
end up with a big disaster on your hands
of nonsense yeah a lot of those would be
political diet that's another one yeah
you know I was learning I was listening
to our podcast sure Andrew and what were
we talking about we were talking I was
talking about watching people in the
news and that's a classic situation
where you've got somebody on a
three-minute segment yeah and one person
is a TV you know the hardcore in this
direction the other person the hardcore
in the other direction they both care
they both care a lot yeah neither one of
them is going to win then they actually
that that goes the next that's the next
realization is that if you're going up
against person that cares as much as you
do you actually have to take a back step
and find another way you have to flank
them yes you're not going to be able to
win them by going head to head they care
is equal to you yeah and I've got to
find a new solution otherwise you know
what you'll do expend all your
ammunition charging machine gun nests
and you will die yeah that you don't
want to do that if you care as much as
me and I don't have the same opinion
I've got a flank you yeah a lot of these
probably gonna let you think you just
won the argument in order to fight you
too by the way yeah yeah the again
political religion diet how to raise
kids you know these are all yeah what do
you hot-button is that what you call it
things that I'm not supposed to talk to
or talk about around the Thanksgiving
dinner yeah they get heated real quick
and you and a lot of times we're talking
about people or not people but we talk
about how much someone cares about it
right and a lot of times the things that
get mixed up is how much you care about
it versus how much you care about your
stance on it yeah there's so many
different buttons and different rap but
even you got to put your ego into both
those right that would be great so now
you go I don't want to admit that I'm
wrong right that's allowed to do that
that means you care about your stance so
when you make a buy yourself time but if
you care about the issue like if I say
if I mean you were having a debate the
debate about kettle bell workouts or
something that I like dumbbells you like
cannibal but I really care about the
issue and the issue is what's the best
exercise if I truly care about what the
best exercises and not about my stance
on what effect I'm going to care about
real answer reddit with its Lancer or
not so that's why I think like political
all these other things they have that
and it is it's just like I said to the
ego yeah natural thing but they wind up
caring more about their stance on it
then they do the actual issues you know
for sure
don't let that happen watch out for that
one so yeah that $0.90 not 97 but the
person who cares the most wins doesn't
apply to someone's individual stance on
something it has to subject and it also
doesn't apply to you know introduce you
match I might really care about winning
this thing about the other day because
that's another thing people say mental
oh it's all mental
and here's an example Alex Honnold who's
a rock climber who just climbed El
Capitan in Yosemite which is 3,000 feet
tall and you people say oh it's all
mental and and people say things you
know if you want something bad enough do
it you put me on that rock there's a
some crux move like 2,000 feet up 2,000
feet up that's really hard and you're
smearing which is this technique and
rock climbing where you don't and I've
done it before and I'm like the lowest
white belt I'm not even a white belt
like I'd like someone gave me my white
belt to rock climbing I'm not I'm not
like a legit but I know I've tried
things I go to Yosemite and I'll play
around on the rocks and everything but
I've tried this thing it's called
smearing and and you're basically just
using the tread or just the bottom of
your rock climbing shoes on flat granite
mmm and you can create enough friction
ridges that you can you can move up it
and some people are really good at it I
just suck and you know you gotta have
your gut your hand holds you're working
to but you're using your feet and it's
this really weird balance that you have
to do because if you push too hard to
the rocks then your feet slip off and if
you don't push hard enough you don't get
any lift so it's this really fine like
balance you've got to have and
apparently there's one move or this one
series of moves on this climb that he
did that is assume you have to smear of
course this is very natural for him but
apparently he climbed that section with
a rope like six or seven times
to make sure it felt good and all that
stuff here's my point
even if it wasn't a smear part even if
it was just holding on to rocks right at
2,000 feet
I would absolutely want really really
badly to hold on to the rocks
I don't have the muscular strength and
do it I mean the things that he's
holding on to are smaller than will the
first pad of your fingers that's what
he's holding on to be tiny and we were
doing this the other day at my house
remember yep that little thing you
actually had bet had stronger grip than
me on the on the climbing board that I
have at my house but I could I could
couldn't even hold on or I could hold on
for five seconds and you like had to
know it did you hold on to the really
small one yeah yeah that's legit I can't
even hold on to that thing so if I was
2,000 feet up and I really really really
really really really wanted to do it and
I was all mentally in the game guess
what I'm falling to my death right
because I don't have the strength to do
it
I don't have the physical strength and I
need to build it and okay you could say
and that that might be an acceptable
answer okay if you really have the
mental strength and will to do it then
you'll train train super hard right but
at that moment not gonna help me I'm
falling to my death right yeah I think
that's a metaphor but like it's it's
like April man yeah it would be oh yeah
it's a romantic thing yeah yeah yeah I
want it bad enough yeah and do it no
actually not true but I want to do I
want to take the extreme version I want
to stay alive I'm 2,000 feet up I want
really badly to stay alive doesn't
matter I can't get across that section I
can't don't have the hand strength to do
it
not happening yeah but they're making a
movie about that I can't wait to see it
about Alex Honnold climbing that rock
Jimmy chin is the famous kind of
photographer guy that they went and
documented the whole thing and
apparently one of the articles said that
during that crux moment Alex Honnold was
like hey when we get to here just like
back off with the cameras he apparently
was like you know just back off the
cameras when I go through you know
section 94 alpha coz what I think he
thought he didn't need any cameras
around real close when he might fall to
his death
eh it's bad heavy yeah like will or is
it because it might break his
concentration or both I don't know I
don't know but that's crazy
yeah have your video somebody know it's
it's El Capitan is 3,000 feet straight
up of granite it takes people 3 4 5 days
to climb up it he climbed it in 3 hours
and 45 minutes with a chalk bag and a
pair of shoes it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous
yeah completely ridiculous 3,000 feet
that's very tall echo you're trying to
imagine it let me he'll know I mean a
halogen anything you've ever seen it's
taller than a skyscraper and pray it
goes it's just huge any climb bitten
with no ropes that means there's no rest
that means there's no break yeah and it
means there's no mistakes you can't make
a mistake if you make a mistake you die
yeah crazy very impressive I don't even
know why we're talking about Alex
Honnold right now oh because we're
talking about the lentil will yeah yeah
well whoever believes it the most yeah I
mean whoever believes the most wins all
cares about it sorry not believe there's
good as much as I care about staying
alive I wouldn't be able to pull it off
yeah I think in Jade's situation that it
did make sense though you know cuz
you're you know no not does make sense
yeah it does make sense and that's why I
was able to do a lot of stuff that I've
been able to do in my career when I was
in the military a lot of the stuff that
I was able to get done I was able to get
done because I cared about it whatever
else okay yeah I like you you think
you're gonna you know you think you're
going to out perform my task unit I care
about this so much I don't care I care
about this so much you're not gonna be
able to compete with me yes because you
might think I'll get there at five
o'clock in the morning I've been there
for an hour you might think I'm going to
have my guys drill this ten times I'm
gonna have my guys drill at 20 times I
care about this too much for you to win
can't beat me you can't beat me it's not
going to happen I care about this too
much not in a bad way not in a selfish
way I care about this as I love this
right this is everything to me you know
you have other things going on and you
got your wife and you got your family
you got this other thing going on in
your life and you got goals that you
want I don't care about any of those
things this is all I care about
so therefore you can't compete with me
hmm and that's pretty cool it's a cool
place to be right we get overseas people
are thinking about all these other
things no you don't care about anything
I don't care about anything else this is
the only thing I care about
mmm so it ends up getting boiled down to
just not stopping right not not cleaning
not giving up yeah that definitely plays
a role that definitely is a role I am of
course there's got to be balanced
because if let's say I don't care about
let's say you know my focus is 100% my
steel task unit but then I forget about
the fact that we're working with other
army units only thing I care about is my
unit well no actually need to care about
the mission more right I need to care
about our strategic where we're going
strategically because otherwise I'm
thinking I just want to get my guys
taking care of I just want to get my
guys more work I just want to get no
actually I I do what care what Trump's
my care for the task unit was care for
the mission of what we're trying to
accomplish now luckily those two things
are completely aligned so there was
never any time where I was thinking oh
should I do this to benefit the tasking
or benefit the mission no no if it
benefited the mission it benefited
asking if it benefited asking it
benefited the mission period so I care
about those things he can have a hard
time competing with me and luckily in
Ramadi
there wasn't any competition we were all
working together that's what was so
amazing about it yeah was Army Marine
Corps us everyone was just working
together to accomplish missions because
that's what you get when you get a nasty
battlefield you get people working
together all right another piece this is
a guy named general mom cell war is
pre-eminently the art of the man who
dares to take the risk of the man who
think deeply and clearly of the man who
when accident intervenes is not thereby
cast down but changes his plans and
disposition with the readiness of a
resolute and reflective mind which so
far as is possible has foreseen and
provided against difficult
tee's there you go that's what we're
talking about Oh accident intervenes
cool good
I'm not cast down change plans adapt
back book no now no man can inspire
confidence and others who is not
confident in himself and self confidence
comes from knowledge a thorough
understanding of modern weapons and
organization tactics and the details
Administration affecting all those under
his command must therefore be acquired
by every leader he must show his troops
that he can plan soundly lead resolutely
and deal promptly and effectively with
the unexpected in addition to gain full
confidence of his troops a leader must
have their personal friendship and trust
I like that again I've there was a there
was a seal officer that once was
briefing guys and said hey if your guys
if your if your people like you they
then they you're not doing a good job
and not true he's actually saying they
need your trust and personal friendship
and trust yeah what you saying something
like that they even that you can't push
that too far well of court right it
means you gotta bounce down on me a
leadership you can't be such close
friends that you're choosing them that
you're putting one person as more
important than the mission or the team
and that's the dichotomy a leadership
okay now he puts together this list
which yeah we're feeling pretty good
about this one a shortlist to leadership
given as follows perfect your military
knowledge study the use of weapons their
tactical handing the enemies character
and methods and way to make use of
ground so I don't care what job you're
in apply those right know your tools
know the enemy know your competitor next
study the men under your command know
them well and be known to them gain
their confidence by your knowledge
energy and skill and by your interest in
their welfare always be cheerful with
however you may feel teach yourself to
think out reason depreciations
leading to clever but uncomplicated
plans quickly and unheard Li so there
you go keep things simple no your people
get I like says know your people get
them to know you too yeah that's
important next study methods of
deception and make full use of them
always aim at misleading the enemy
always seek surprised keep your object
clearly before you concentrate your
efforts and resources at the decisive
point always think well ahead prioritize
mexic you work out the best methods of
control in different tactical situations
practice them constantly study the
situation carefully don't waste any time
make up your mind and stick to it
get out your orders quickly make certain
that everyone clearly knows what you
intend it to be done commander's intent
maintain the initiative make
opportunities and seize them at once I
like that make opportunities oh I do I
like that don't wait for them to come be
prepared to take risks but don't be
foolhardy no your commanders intention
and act in accordance with it don't wait
for orders inaction is always wrong so
there you go what this is just
reiterating things that I talk about all
the time never take counsel of your
fears think of the enemy's difficulties
in how you can take advantage of them
remember that it is willpower that wins
oh he's going off there's nothing about
carry instead of my will which will goes
a long way never relax your efforts
until victory is won attend to the
comfort of the troops before you think
of your own this is all just phenomenal
stuff be loyal to your superiors and
your subordinates express your views
clearly and frankly but when a decision
has been reached fully supported and
stopped all criticism never take shelter
behind others when things for which you
are responsible have gone wrong take
some ownership oh I like this one
refrain from jealousy resentment and
self seeking be tactful never make
friction be thoughtful and considerate
but maintain firm discipline they think
about how bad this thing about the
dichotomy that be thoughtful and
considerate but maintain foreign
discipline never order troops to do what
you are not prepared to do yourself
never give an unnecessary order that's a
good one think about that one never give
an unnecessary order and I'll tell you
why I like that one it is because if
you're doing a good job as a leader
orders should barely even be necessary
yeah they should barely even be
necessary talk about this with life the
other day I am weak I'm sure we could go
back through you know the history of
tasking a bruiser but as we were having
a conversation we were working with a
company I don't think I ever gave an
order to either one of my two platoon
commanders either life or the Delta
platoon commander I don't think I ever
said this is what you're going to do
that's an order
like you see in the movies all right
well we're going to ask you they say
that do they ever say does anyone ever
do that there's a tail order if you yes
it can be said yeah I'm trying to think
I'm sure it's been I I I think it's been
said to me before no more like in admit
like non-administrative situation
gosh I don't know if anyone's ever said
it to me before like that's an order I
don't know I'm trying to think of
there's been some situation where
someone said to me like hey basically
like you've pushed far enough taco stand
down I got in one of those before
like hey we get it Jocko you care about
this a lot it's not happening stand down
oughta goggles especially got those
like when I was a young enlisted god of
driving with an ID I'd just be wanting
to crush it and people would be kind of
saying hey well no we can't borrow and
I'd be like no I can't why can't we why
want why want why won't we do this you
need to do this this is the smart thing
to you know it's the right thing to do
and I would just eventually get like the
little hey stand down we're not doing it
okay you know what I'm gonna do become
an officer I want to listen to you
anymore
so yeah I've got I think I've got a
couple stand downs in my time stand down
that's in order cuz yet that's an order
that when you think of our anyway when I
think but it really does seem like a
movie line yeah and one thing is that
means that you have not done a good job
as a leader if I have to say that's an
order really means I haven't done this
good job as a leader that means you
don't understand the mission you don't
understand it intent you don't
understand
I haven't conveyed it to you properly
and the only way I can get you to listen
is by saying if that's an order yeah a
plane rank yeah
pulling rank on you that's not a good
not a good situation back to the book
never overlook failure to carry one out
so it's never given unnecessary order
never overlooked failure to carry one
out some people have to chime in with
their opinions on that one never
overlook failure to carry one out I'm
not sure on that one
what does that mean to carry one that's
I'm saying I don't know it says it says
never order troops to do what you're not
prepared to do yourself never give an
unnecessary order never overlook failure
to carry one out to carry out an order
yeah to carry one out never overlook
failure to carry one out I'm not sure
what he means by that look I'm sure what
some people will give us some opinions
on that one on the Facebook you when I
release keep fit yourself and make
certain that your men do to keep your
own nerves under control and study your
men's good
for like when you want to comment if
you're listening and you want to comment
you have an opinion on that one put it
on the Facebook post so it can follow
the conversation as opposed to Twitter
which is 140 characters you know what I
mean
oh yeah it's easier to see it on
Facebook when there's a legit question
or someone has some legit big feedback
if you put it on the thread for podcast
number 81 when I post it that's the
place to put in there in the replies
yeah when I can like converse back on
that subject without having to go
through 17,000 tweets
yeah I mean go back and forth they
replay your hand but not here yeah so
it's all laid out on Facebook so it's a
good place to have those little
conversations Twitter we have different
kinds of conversations sure last of all
remember that success in war depends
more than anything else on the will to
win cool again now we got Monty saying
more Al's most important
we got Jocko saying leadership is most
important and you got Brigadier General
monsell saying that the will to win is
the most important I'm not going to
actually argue with either one of these
guests yeah together all got all kinds
of experience but much more intense than
mine
speaking of intense experience more than
mine there's a guy a pseudonym meaning a
fake name
Basilisk and the guy wrote something
called talks on leadership and the guy's
actual name was Alfred burned and he was
a World War 1 and World War two veteran
then he was a military historian and
he's got a little section in here called
being straight there's one trait in the
character of a leader that above all
things really counts and it perhaps
counts in war even more than in peace
being straight no amount of ability
knowledge or cunning can ever make up
for not being straight once those under
him find out that a commander
absolutely straight in all his dealings
with them and free from the slightest
trade of self-interest other than the
self-interest of which we are all guilty
when striving for victory of causes we
believe to be right they will love him
as their leader trust him work for him
follow him and should the occasion arise
die for him with the fundamental ability
of the British soldier which comes to
the surface when things are at their
worst
so being straight with you people very
important very important in fact perhaps
his most important above all so now we
got another factor that's the most
important thing now it can hear a little
on leadership from Field Marshal Lord a
herring once again World War 1 and World
War 2 veteran he also fought the Second
Battle of alameen he was wounded lost
some fingers recovered got back to the
fight so he says about leadership here
there are some people who believe that
leadership is something which is inborn
or which you acquire automatically at a
public school but neither of those
things are true there are certain
fundamental qualities which affect
leadership and which depend to a very
large extent on upbringing and the moral
and spiritual values which you can learn
which you learn in your family and in
your environment as a young man but
there is no special way nor is there any
special caste or class which has the
prerogative of leadership there are many
forms of leadership political parties
have their leaders every big
organization in industry or commerce all
have their leaders and at the other end
of the scale so do dance bands and so do
gangs of thieves and smugglers there are
many qualities that apply equally to
every type of leader but you and I are
concerned with one particular type of
leadership to my mind the highest type
of all and that is a leadership on the
battlefield and I believe it to be
highest type because it has to be
exercised under conditions of great
difficulty and considerable danger I
would like to be quite I would like you
to be quite clear about the conditions
under which you will have to exercise
leadership you will frequently be tired
you may also be cold and wet and hungry
and thirsty you may be dripping with
sweat or you may be freezing with cold
you won't know precisely what is going
on you won't know exactly where the
enemy is you certainly won't know what
he is going to do or what his
capabilities are of doing anything you
may not know where your own people are
or what they are going to do to put it
briefly you've got to be able to
exercise leadership and conditions of
fatigue and fear uncertainty and
ignorant and often in isolation that is
what makes it extremely difficult and
that is why leadership on the
battlefield calls in my view for the
highest qualities many qualities are
required and leader different people
have different views about which are
more important in my opinion there are
five outstanding mental and physical
moral and spiritual qualities without
which you cannot hope to be successful
and a good leader on the battlefield the
first of those qualities is a mental and
physical one and that is fitness
absolute fitness of mind and body so
make sure you're getting your morning
physical training in physical fitness
mental fitness next then I would say
you've got to have complete integrity
you've got to be honest not only with
yourselves but with the men you lead and
the people with whom you work and
honesty and integrity are things that
you cannot compromise with you cannot
alter if you do you will lose confidence
and you will not be able to lead you
must have complete integrity
so that's the same thing as being
straight yeah not after that not in any
next sorry next after that not in any
order of priority but this is how I have
put them down deep in my mind there is
an enduring courage pretty well everyone
can be brave for a few minutes most of
us can if we steal ourselves to it take
one pledge or make one decision or incur
one risk but the sort of courage you
must have to lead on the battlefield is
an enduring courage and one that you
will go that will go on when other
people falter one that will enable you
to do what you know to be right
irrespective of the danger or the
difficulty contrary often contrary to
the advice of well-meaning friends so
gotta have courage next then you must
have daring initiative initiative means
doing right away what you might if you
had time think of doing a few minutes
later I like this if you wait for things
to happen to you they will happen
alright and Here I am quoting the words
of my predecessor also spoken here they
will happen to you but they won't be
what you like and they certainly won't
bring you success initiative means
seeing at once and very quickly what
needs to be done making up your mind to
do it and then seeing it through to the
middle at bitter end so I love that one
if you wait for things to happen to you
they certainly will
a little bit more on willpower here then
you must have undaunted willpower the
willpower is the motive power it is what
enables you to make yourself fit in mind
and body to producing you in your heart
the courage the enduring courage that I
spoke of to give you the courage to do
your duty and to make the sacrifice that
may be called from you
it is the willpower that forces you to
take the initiative to make the plan to
do what is required to see it through
and that willpower must be undaunted it
must never allow itself to be overcome
or subdued perhaps the finest example
living today of the power and influence
for good of man with undaunted willpower
as our prime minister in one of the
critical periods of the last war he
spoke certain words I am going to quote
you now he said all the great struggles
in history have been won by superior
willpower resting victory in the teeth
of odds or upon the narrowest of margins
it is the willpower that is superior
that can wrest victory and the teeth of
odds that is the type of willpower that
has got to be developed in a leader on
the battlefield mobilize your will now
he talks about some other qualities he
talks about knowledge he talks about
judgment he talks about keen spirit
saying because you cannot get success on
the battlefield by yourself you've got
to work with other people so obviously
as a leader you have to have that spirit
of teamwork and closing out he says
there's one other thing I would like to
say to you as British officers you will
never have all you want all you need
you'll be short of this or that or the
other sometimes you will be short of men
other times your equipments or weapons
may not be as good
you think they ought to be nor will you
have as many as you would like you may
be short of ammunition you may also be
short of food and water or other
necessary things when these
circumstances arise as they do often
throughout your service both in Keis and
war there's only one motto and that is
to make certain that you do the very
best you can with what you've got
don't bellyache about what you have not
got but get on and make certain you do
your utmost with what you have got now
to sum up what I've tried to say this
afternoon I would like to put it like
this first keep fit absolutely fit then
be honest honest with yourselves and
honest with those with whom you work
then have courage and make it an
enduring courage next be bold be daring
and when there is a choice take the bold
and daring course make the very most of
what you have got and never never never
give in yes
do what you can with what you've got
until you really like that one I like
sometimes is that attracted me alright
next there's a chapter in this book
which is called discipline which makes
me very happy and again I tried to
censor myself from not just doing the
entire chapter obviously you can buy
this book if you want to see the whole
thing there's some great points this
first one is from Field Marshal Earl
Wavell who was in the Boer Wars and he
was in World War one and in World War
two lost his left eye in the Battle of
Ypres so what we're talking a warrior
here that was went back for service
here's what he said about discipline
discipline is teaching which makes a man
do something which he would not unless
he had learned that it was the right the
proper and the expedient thing to do at
its best it is instilled and maintained
by pride in one's self in one's unit in
one's profession only at its worst by
fear of punishment so he's talking we
want self-discipline we don't want
imposed discipline that's what he's
saying you don't want I don't want you
doing this because you're scared of me
if you don't do what I tell you I'm
going to beat you that's not what I want
I want you're saying I'm going to do
this because I want to do it here's a
little something from Monty here and
we're gonna get some disagreements going
I'm going to disagree with Monty sorry
Monty was you're here to defend yourself
okay on discipline Monty the basis of
training must be self-disciplined cool a
man must learn to be the master of
himself and to keep in subjection the
bad qualities in his makeup I love that
self-discipline can be developed by
training in such things as conception of
duty self control self
respect endurance and so on we then have
collective discipline and there's no
doubt that the initial training in this
subject is best carried out by drill men
must be taught instinctively to obey
orders whatever they are I do not
believe men will fight voluntarily for a
cause without the iron bonds of
discipline the best form of discipline
is subordination of self for the benefit
of the community so I'm going to make
some comments on those number one when
you saying that you should obey orders
regardless of what they are don't agree
I don't agree that I want my men to
question my orders I want them to if I'm
telling them to do something that they
don't think is smart I want them to
question me hmm I want them to come up
with then a better solution that's how
we're gonna win even the moral thing to
right like to obey orders regardless oh
yeah but there are oral for sure for
sure I want my whole team to be hey if
this is the wrong thing to do we
shouldn't be doing it
yeah next the other one he says here is
he says that people won't fight for a
cause without the iron bonds of
discipline I don't believe that that's
true either and I think if you look at
American history guys we didn't have
this strict love of course there's this
discipline of course in the military and
there's imposed discipline in the
military but the things that people and
all soldiers have accomplished without
strict imposed discipline is they've
given their lives over and over and over
thousands and thousands and thousands
and hundreds of thousands of cases where
men have given their lives not because
not because I said or because the leader
said go and charge this machine-gun nest
that's that's not why they did it they
did it because they believed in the
cause so I don't agree with that one I
think that men will fight voluntarily
for a cause
without the iron bonds of discipline and
you know what I think they do it I think
they do it when that causes freedom so
when the cause is freedom I believe men
will fight without the bonds of
discipline over them and this idea that
the best form of discipline is the
subordination of self for the benefit of
the community I don't actually agree
with that one either I think the best
form of discipline is when there is
alignment in the discipline the
discipline for the team and the
individual bring success and survival
and freedom and when those things are
aligned that's when I think you get the
finest form of discipline now he
recovers a little bit from my criticism
here and of course to everyone that is
wondering why I'm sort of making fun of
myself
it's pretty embarrassing to be sitting
here and disagreeing with a guy like
Monty so please don't take me the wrong
way just giving my opinion here and I'm
in no way comparing my military
knowledge with general Montgomery and he
doesn't say this the basis of all
discipline is self discipline which this
is beautiful when I agree with that
hundred percent this this self
discipline may come from within a person
or may be imposed upon him from without
don't agree that'll only last a little
while whatever it serves its source it
involves the idea of self control and
self restraint that is true but there is
I think it's called
situational discipline I think or what
is that I could I could have the
expression wrong but I think either
situational just meaning like if you're
in a certain situation you'll have
you'll be really self disciplined but
once you get out you're not you know
like um I don't know you ever you ever
watch watch the B is a show called The
Biggest Loser now so yeah the only
people that are having weight problems
they go on a show they get fed certain
things made to workout I lose a bunch of
weight and then they win the program and
then when they go back home and they're
not around that imposed discipline right
they lose it right that's my point
yeah my point is that that imposed
discipline it works if while you have
the impose er yeah they're asking you
what I would prefer is to have someone
that makes a change in their mindset and
develops itself this right now sometimes
you can get that from imposed discipline
and you realize like you get shown the
freedom that it discipline gives you and
then you carry on with it like a lot of
people that listen to the podcast and
they've done incredible things with
their lives because we weren't there to
impose discipline on them but they
recognize themselves maybe they said
okay you know what I'm going to get up
for the next two weeks and we get up
earlier more workout I'm going to eat
healthy two weeks go by they've lost a
little bit of body fat they've gained a
little bit of muscle and they feel good
right and all of a sudden they realize
the benefits of discipline and so they
change their mindset they become more
disciplined human beings yeah that's
what I like yeah when I don't like is it
I'll run a boot camp on you and yell at
you and screaming I think people want me
to yell and scream I get that I think
once or twice a day someone will say you
need to make an alarm clock where you
yell and tell us tell me to get out of
bed yeah and I say get psychological
warfare but I'm not going to yell in
psychological warfare because yelling
isn't an effective tool compared to
actually speaking to someone and letting
them understand why it's important yeah
that's the preferred tool occasionally
you got to yell at people occasionally
yes you do occasionally not very often
though yes pretty rare huh
but yeah that yeah right now with that
situational discipline because even I
think about what's worse somebody
yelling at you or someone whispering at
you it's actually worse isn't it some
ways yeah in a lot of ways yeah to me
it's worse
sure yelling and screaming just doesn't
know and it really doesn't really matter
what they're saying either if you choose
what yelling or whisper because like you
know even if they're telling you a
normal thing like hey here this is what
I want from the store I want avocados
tomatoes and you know some wine but what
if I whisper it to you hey Chuck that
come here bro
am i freaked me out actually yeah yes so
you didn't hear about that exist no no
you get that's that's the point doesn't
really matter what they're saying
whispering versus oh yeah it definitely
has a different psychological effect for
sure yeah that was me free fat you being
a joke when you pick up a bottle of wine
okay no actually I can't I'm leaving
yeah the wine kind of makes it extra
awkward for sure
all right so now we get into another
part on discipline right here and this
is Sir John Fortescue and when you pay
attention to this one cousin we circle
in sideways I have in my mind rather
those excellent but generally unthinking
persons who shrink with horror from the
idea of a man's abdicating his civil
rights what they say a man must obey
even an unjust command under pain it may
be of death it is monstrous for purposes
of civil life it might be monstrous but
not for the purposes of implicit
obedience which is the thing that
matters in the army let there be justice
as far as possible by all means but as a
general principle it is better for an
army that an injustice should be done
than that an order should be disobeyed
this however is an argument that cannot
appeal to our to our imaginary objector
because he has read no military history
so
that's just very disturbing this whole
thing and it really doesn't comply with
anything that I say which is I want you
to question orders if they're not good
orders you shouldn't obey Him and he
said no no no it's better to do
something unjust as long as you're
obeying orders and I did a little bit of
research about John Fortescue and you
know obviously I don't agree with this
and actually in the new version of the
book he the the guy that writes the
forward to the new version of this
specifically calls out John Fortescue
and says we removed him the him these
are gone from the book thing and what I
found out about him was yes he was in
the army
he was a major in the army but I don't
think he was in any combat and what I do
know is that he was the Royal librarian
from 1905 until 1926 and he died in 1923
so he didn't go to World War one really
all these other guys are World War One
World War two veterans he was the life
of royal librarian and it's interesting
when he says because he has read no
military doesn't said because he's never
been in combat before he says he's read
an exec of the person that would object
this is never read military history well
okay I clearly theory yeah he's going
with the theory yeah and and if you want
to take this and stretch it out more
broadly this attitude you know I hate
World War one I hate World War one
because it was so based on obedience and
you are going to charge we're going to
charge this trench all 7,000 of us are
going to charge tomorrow morning at 0
6:30 we're to go over the top where you
get mowed down by machine guns and then
the people are going to follow us and do
the same thing and they've guys were so
obedient
and brave and just selfless to do that
but this attitude is what made that war
so devastating because no one said hey
wait a second this doesn't seem smart to
me yeah I just watched you know of two
three four battalions or two three four
regiments get mowed down and now you're
telling me I'm gonna do the same thing
tomorrow with my men no I want you to
question my orders I want you to say no
if I'm making you do something that
doesn't make sense I want you to say no
and if I can't explain it to you in a
logical way then I should rethink what
I'm saying to you so mr. John Fortescue
we're gonna have to say that we've kind
of changed our opinion on on obedience
and there are more important things and
then obedience in a team in a military
team and in the business world here's
another piece from this going back to
General William slim any army without
discipline is no more than a mob
alternating between frightened sheep and
beasts of prey discipline as the British
soldiers demonstrated in peace and war
is the old Christian virtue of
unselfishness of standing by your
neighbor your comrade it is the
sacrifice of a man's comfort inclination
safety even life for others for
something greater than himself
it is the refusal to be the weak link in
the chain that snaps under under strain
and this is a great little story here
one paragraph back to book once from the
safety of a well dug command post I
looked down on a battery of artillery in
action in the African bush it was firing
at five rounds per gun per minute and
idly I timed the nearest gun in that
area the enemy unfortunately had
complete local air supremacy and guns
unless engaged in some vital task were
ordered to remain silent
whenever hostile aircraft appeared
gradually dominating all other sounds
came the dull drone of bombers flying
low but
guns went on firing five rounds per gun
permitted for they were supporting an
infantry attack cover move by the way
the first stick of bombs fell around the
gun I was watching some of its crew were
hit the dry brush roared into flame
which spread instantly to the camouflage
nets over the gun it vanished from my
sight in smoke and flame yet from the
very midst of that inferno at the exact
intervals came the flash and thud of the
firing gun five rounds per minute per
gun never a falter never a second doubt
no weak link there the discipline held
that's pretty awesome
sections here talking about duty and
service and we're going to first start
with Colonel George Henderson a British
officer who fought in Egypt and at the
Battle of Casson and he fought the Boer
Wars as well and he talks about Waterloo
here we go back to the book no incident
is more familiar in our military history
than the stubborn resistance of the
British line at Waterloo through the
long hours of the midsummer day silent
and immovable squares and squadrons
stood in the trampled corn harassed by
an almost incessant fire of cannon and
musketry to which they were forbidden to
make reply not a moment but heard some
cry of agony not a moment but some
comrade fell headlong into the furrows
yet as bullets of the skirmishers hailed
around them and the great shot tore
through the tight packed ranks the word
was passed quietly close in on the
centre men and as the Sun neared its
setting the regiment's still shoulder to
shoulder stood fast upon the ground they
had held at noon the spectacle is
characteristic in good fortune and an
ill it is rare indeed that a British
regiment does not hold together and this
indestructible cohesion best of all
qualities that an armed body can possess
is based not merely on hereditary
resolution but on mutual confidence and
mutual respect the man and the ranks has
implicit faith in his officer the
officer and almost unbounded belief in
the valor and discipline of his men
and that I've talked about this and
people want to know what makes the SEAL
Teams do well the thing that makes the
SEAL Teams do well is the bond that
holds them together and that bond is so
strong that it's unbreakable and that's
why seals do well in combat because we
have a bond that is unbreakable stronger
than anything that's going to get thrown
at us
the Brotherhood is gonna stand and I'm
going to close this book out with two
more quotes and speaking of Waterloo
this one is from Wellington and this is
a very simple quote he said my rule was
always to do the business of the day in
the day and I I was reading this book
the other day and I actually posted
something about it but I I was I didn't
realize I was thinking about this but we
have a saying in the SEAL Teams plan
your dive and dive your plan is the same
so when you're when you're doing a
combat swimmer attack which is when
you're on a rebreather and you're diving
underwater and what if you've ever done
before if you don't understand this it's
very hard to comprehend what combat
swimmers like but I'll give you a real
quick brief when you're doing a combat
dive on Italy breather you basically
can't see anything it's nighttime you're
down at 10 12 15 feet underwater it's
black you can't see anything there's no
like fish swimming around there's no sea
life to look at there's no coral reef
it's black you can't see anything the
only thing you can actually see is
something called an attack aboard which
an attack board
sounds really cool but let me tell you
what it is it's a piece of plastic woman
it used to be wood that has on it a
depth gauge a compass
and the watch to time and so you put
little tiny chem-lights little glowing
camera and you actually tape them up so
that they're barely emitting any light
at all and you put one by the stopwatch
one by the compass and one by the depth
gauge and when you're underwater so you
have those things they're basically
strapped on to this board that you hold
I don't know it's like like - about the
size of a piece of paper right of
eight-and-a-half by eleven piece paper
that's about how big this board is and
on it you've got your depth gauge your
compass and your stopwatch and you can
barely see them they're glowing very
faintly and when you're underwater
that's all you can see it is just that
you can't see anything else occasionally
you'll get like some weird abstract
light from the moon or something but
even that's rare because you're down
underwater and if you ever been in water
with low visibility sometimes that
sometimes it's actually hard to see the
attack board that's two feet in front of
your face so then what you're doing is
you're looking at that compass you're
looking at that depth gauge and you're
looking at the stopwatch
and you have pre-planned legs that
you're going on you're going to go this
long this this bearing this long this
depth for this time and when I say so
you're kicking looking at this board for
an hour and 17 minutes then you're going
to make a 90-degree turn and you're
going to go for another 48 minutes and
then you're going to make a right turn
for 12 minutes and you're going to hit
your target then you're going to turn
around do some other route back out as
long as you can stay underwater you
stand of water then eventually you run
out of oxygen you come to the surface
and you swim the rest of the way to your
extract any visions of the glory and the
fun of being a seal this is it's not
it's work and it's hard work and you
have to concentrate the whole time and
you got to make sure you don't go too
shallow or too deep if you go too
shallow you'll be seen if you go too
deep you're can go off the the dive
tables that you're allowed to be on
oxygen for so you've got to focus the
whole time then by the way your despair
and your buddy that's with you
he's even more miserable than you are
because he has no idea what's going on
he's just trying to keep up with you
because for some reason the way you dive
the way you put your body when you have
the attack board you can swim a little
bit faster than the guy that's looking
around and making sure that you're not
going to hit anything and make sure not
so there's only one tack board put in
here there's a one attack book for
prepare sometimes we would make to make
a smaller attack board just because it
was so much more efficient to fly with
them but you can't fly you if you're the
buddy
you're you can't be just looking at the
attack board you have to look around
attack board the attack board attack
that's what we call the attack board so
with all that the reason I'm telling you
all this is that when you're underwater
it's really easy to get confused and
turned around and sometimes you go over
big pieces of metal that are in the
water and your compass starts to like
wander around and you can't communicate
with your buddy no no that's what it
sounds like man you've got so we know we
have squeeze signals and sometimes we
carry grease pens to write but it never
there's no real effective way to
communicate underwater so you're just in
this dark just cold blind situation four
three two three four hours at a time and
the saying is that we have is plan your
dive and dive your plan because if you
and I go underwater and then we start
trying to adjust things while we're
underwater and we just we think we're
going to do something different once we
go first of all you and I to be thinking
two different things and then it's going
to be a disaster so we we plan our dive
and dive our plan and that's reminded me
of this statement do the business of the
day in the day yeah right get done what
you say you're going to get done do it
and how simple is that
and it's like dive your plan and what I
said the other day I said plan what
you're going to do and then do what you
planned that's real simple
yeah and and think of how far you're
going to think of where you will be in
two weeks if every day you plan what
you're going to do then you do what you
planned yeah it's it's amazing yeah it
seems so that
that'll does what we're talking about a
few weeks ago where it's like
distractions that's the thing you know
I've seen there's like just industries
of distractions yeah for sure you never
wake up I was explaining my
eight-year-old daughter the other day
that they design cuz she was playing a
game on iPad oh yeah well what are you
learning from that and she said what do
you mean I said oh are you learning
anything from that she said well I you
have to get these rings as it oh so
you're not learning anything from that
yeah and she said I don't I don't I said
you know what they do they make that
game to make you want to play it more if
there's no there's no man to the Gators
no other way they just want you to play
that game keep clicking on that types of
yeah but there look you know of course
I'm just being a total jerk I'm like
yeah look at how they are how well it
works look at you you can't look at you
you you look at you holding onto this
thing and she doesn't falses anymore
when she was younger I used to go up and
and press her head as if her head was
getting softer I'd look at her like oh
man how long have you been on this for
and you say I don't know and it's a I
think if you stop now your brain might
harden back up eventually probably do
the same thing with with her uh her
muscles like meaning like chips aside
any tips there's like oh your muscle
getting like all soft right now yeah
like a she's young before so it works
yeah also it works but they do they play
plan these things so the bait addicted
yeah those iPad ones there's no end well
everything is designed that right right
maybe I'm you talk about the Facebook
app that shows the little thing that
shows oh yeah likely an SLR here and
this might be the message that I've been
waiting for right variable reward it
might not be so that's the thing that's
if you know guaranteed it was going to
be consistently it's less addictive
called variable reward yeah that's what
I'm saying but you see everyone in their
mind is thinking this might be yeah this
link might be a big one exactly I'm
getting contacted by Mike Anisha see
they saw my tweet they're getting back
at these are going to come on the
podcast we're gonna techniques
tenaciously a Jack Black and Kyle Gass
know well is that a movie it's a band
okay from a movie they have been in a
movie yes and then
Jen black Jackie laughter now I got
selected allowed another musician okay
gotcha School of Rock that's not a rock
that's a great shallow hell that's not a
movie that's Jack Black no no he is an
actor like I said in addition to being a
wrong member we look scotch
Eames oh cool why do we just talk about
oh yeah because I think it oh this might
be the tweet that I was waiting for from
tenacious d sure so I gotta check my
Twitter in 47 times a minute yeah no not
happening
you can't you you don't have a tweet
from tenacious B that's not there they
didn't treat you yeah so don't check
your Twitter go and do something
productive yeah but so and that's when
you're already distracted so basically
the point was you know do your power
plan your day or do you know and and do
the plan right yeah because no one plan
your day and do what you plan yeah
that's it so you no one plans to what's
really J well really jacked up is if you
actually took what you did in a day and
you wrote it down and planned it I bet
you could get it done in so much less
time like right now I've got a lot of
stuff going on right now and I'm doing
things that normally take me two hours
I'm doing in 46 minutes same quality by
the way today getting after it right but
you got to put a little suspense date on
something and say let's do here you got
to get it done and then you just sit
down and make it happen yes that's what
you need to do so it's it's one of those
simple with any of these easy things but
this is what so you wouldn't you put in
a way you put these kind of parameters
on what you're going to do and if like
okay I'm making a plan and I'm sticking
to the plan right that's what I'm doing
so I plan to do XYZ excellent you know
all these things yeah and if it so
basically right when you say okay here's
the plan you outline it if it's not in
the plan you just don't do it
it's so yeah so distractions no one
plans like hey tomorrow I'm going to
just eat like crap tomorrow that's the
plan that's never the plan
you know but if you don't have any plan
or nothing sure you allow those things
to come in so
like okay tomorrow and you're not gonna
plan the whole day you're not gonna find
every meal you're not gonna if you did
it would be real effective yeah if you
did you stay on locked right I so much
in the meal prep the night before
exactly when you go to those phases
where you're cooking seven chicken
breasts and you're just ready you got
everything laid out and if you do it
yeah there you go
yeah really people do that every pose in
degrees and it works yes sir yeah
exactly right so and is it realistic and
really when you think about it kind of
is if you're committed to it well what's
crazy is is it takes more work upfront
how long does it take to prepare all
your meals for the week and by the way I
don't do this
yeah but how long I've done it before
how longs it take preparing meals it
takes you two hours two hours and 20
minutes let's say same amount of time by
the when you get done preparing those
and you save time in the week right
because now you're not sitting around
just get redeploying your pots and pans
redeploying your stove settings and all
that other stuff and you actually are
going to save time you know if you plan
your day yeah and then you do your plan
yeah and think about this if you use a
meal prep example where okay you don't
typically we don't plan on every meal
for a week
typically we just don't do that but when
you do the meal prep planning situation
you're saying are we meeting human
beings in nearly every way is that
technical person so that's a good
example when you do that now boom that
your meals a element of your life that
typically isn't quote unquote planned is
now planned so now those parameters are
set so anything outside those parameters
you just don't really think about as
much you know and when they kind of
enter you it's real obvious like hey
that's not part of this plan what the
hell you know it's like it's more it's
like but if you don't plan it they come
in it's kind like whatever there's no
parameters there anyway in my head so
that goes for everything you do
so just like how you're saying yeah I
have a lot of stuff so you plan okay I'm
going to do this here do this now do
this at this time finish it by this time
all this stuff those parameters are set
so the distractions have way hard to
come to get it
so in everyday life you can make some
ambiguous goal hey I want to eat better
know plan by the way just it's an
ambiguous goal there's a parameters on
there so you take one
this step you you know you were at the
stop stoplight for longer than you
expected now you're late for this now
I'm pressed for time there's McDonald's
right and it'll just sneak right in but
if you got those parameters in
McDonald's no not part of my plan right
now yeah my plan I gotta do you know
like a dashiki yeah another thing I if
you're gonna plan your day you should
actually plan to have time in there that
has nothing in it right so you should
you should plan to have a half an hour
where you're where you're gonna address
problems right okay so that way a
problems cuz they're gonna come up yeah
yeah you got to have your your free time
and by free I mean free to go make other
things happen and just and make things
good but what you shouldn't do is say
cuz I tell you there's some things that
I have a really hard time like with the
podcast I'll keep preparing the podcast
I'll just clearing it right I'll just
get all the time I know I go beyond that
because I there's another story that
ties into something else and I'm gonna
go pull out another book and by the way
I gotta run out of time to get it from
Amazon so I'm gonna go to the library
you know I mean you go down where I
could prepare for a podcast forever and
not be ready for it and so I have to put
my own self and check and say okay draw
the line on this level of depth on this
thing now I might make a footnote and
I've kind of cool category now on my
computer that's you know tangents where
I opened a tangent and I didn't close it
on the podcast so now we're going to be
able to enter them at a different time
huh when when time allows because I can
get focused on that one subject so
that's pretty cool yeah but it takes
discipline to do that because otherwise
I would just go down every rabbit yeah
it's enough and you do take a book like
this and there's so many rabbit holes
and there it's almost impossible to stay
out of them yeah it's kind of ridiculous
yeah in a way you go
my point is playing plan your day and
then execute you plan if you do that
it's going to make a huge difference in
your life and what's good you look up
you look up in a month two months
three months the amount of stuff that
you've gotten done is ridiculous
and I'll tell you one of the ways that I
do do that myself is I just cast myself
with die I say I'm gonna do things and
you'll ever have to do yeah our create
that plan if let's say with this podcast
a good example we do this podcast once a
week we've held the line really well on
that if we didn't if we said you know
what let's just put the podcast out when
we put it out yeah if that was the
mindset we had from the beginning we
would probably I'm gonna guess that we
would have less than half of the
podcasts would have been put out that's
my guess because we understood you know
what hey I got a train this week and I'm
gonna miss that and I haven't read the
book that I was going to read so cuz
right now bro yo I've got 15 minutes
that little half hour of my schedule
where I have nothing guess what I'm
doing in that half an hour I'm doing 22
minutes worth of reading of a book
that's coming up yeah that's what I'm
doing if we didn't have the discipline
structure in place that probably
wouldn't be happening yeah yeah that
probably wouldn't be able to do you know
what build time with fire hey bro yeah
let's let's let's let's give this week
and visit so much easier yeah yeah you
know what I was going to go gonna hang
out today I don't really want to do this
today no we're doing it yeah I mean we
signed up for it yep totally now could
it get to a point where say you know
what every two weeks we've mentioned
that before people didn't like that idea
yeah yeah
meaning else didn't like that idea I
didn't like that any better
you know why cuz I like that discipline
yeah why would you know why cuz I'm
basically I'm basically confining myself
to doing something productive as opposed
to watching YouTube videos yeah about
cats because there's some dignity videos
right there's some good YouTube videos
but there's also a lot of them are not
good and you're not getting anything out
of them yes and man the ones that they
rack up for you when you've just got
done watching one yeah
the ones that they rack up for you all
every single one of them where they rack
up I think they rack up four on top and
four on bottom on your little screen
yeah and every one of them is like a
clickbait right every one of them is a
quick thing it's one it's crazy
yeah it's they do that obvious brilliant
yeah because it has a lot to do with
everything that you've you've won for
sure so that it's going to be it's the
next video is always just like it's a
money % relevant to what you
specifically one right there and that is
why that is what you got to get angry at
but you know you know and you have that
uh you know how you have that that way
that you overcame your anger anger
management right but you read that it
was like you had low self-esteem that
we're getting mad well when you get that
when you get that next rack of YouTube
videos staring at you if you should be
getting pissed because you know what
they're trying to do they're trying to
get you trying to take your time away
from you yeah and by the way they're
making money from you click that next
thing they're making they're making
money from what you're doing and so
they've set this system up to make you
click that thing yeah so you're a mark
is what you are you am on your marker
look at you falling for it everywhere
yeah every day that's how I quit
drinking - by the way that is legit like
oh I'm falling for a trick that my brain
is playing on me I'm falling for that
trick won't fall for that trick that and
like I said it's hard to because it's
mixed in with positive stuff on YouTube
there I have really good quality stuff
on YouTube there's some great knowledge
you can gain from YouTube for sure and
if you're good at justifying things yeah
yeah that's true - it's a really scary
yeah but my point is I don't want to
just sit here a bag on YouTube because
it's an incredible source of information
if you keep it informational but it's
real easy to get sideways on that yeah
and they somehow know they can attach
like watching a street fight - because I
watch street fights or I watch a you
know a UFC fighter I'll watch a clip or
I'll watch a submission ok know how to
drag you in you like those clickbait
titles of the guy fighting the kangaroo
yeah man vs. kangaroo unbelievable right
and of course you're thinking yourself
ok
what would I do if I didn't find your
kangaroo yeah I live in America and I'm
not fighting any kangaroos but somehow I
got a click on that video to see what up
well such garbage so good job YouTube
you know and I'm not gonna be a sucker
over here nope not it won't be a mark
give yourself a limit yeah see and that
goes back to yourself like a click limit
on those things yeah
or just set your planet right give you
some parameters right you won't it's it
even me thinking about it right now it
really after you can explain it there it
really puts it into perspective and all
the things you ever I mean you're
different than I think I think a lot of
people where sometimes people only make
plans it's like they have important
stuff something that's important to do
list there's like 10 things on the list
which actually seems like a pretty big
to-do list if you think 10 before yeah
in one day so you know how many things
you do in a day that you can get
distracted from a lot of them yeah more
than 10 it's like a lot and I got
everything everything from like wet the
day you wake up or not the day but the
time you wake up what you eat every
single time by the way oh oh the TV
watcher don't watch I get air every
second of the day if it had a parameter
on it and you just laser focus on all
your goals instead of these ambiguous in
a little movie or I wanted I need to dot
an old XYZ more yeah don't say no thing
the plan doesn't take that much time to
put together yeah and how you said it's
it'll end up saving you time oh for sure
it'll end up in the unaware another will
head minutes that you spend planning the
next day will save you for hours yeah
you can usually get done everything you
have to get done in like half the time
yeah half the crazy and it's weird too
because I don't know why I'm not pull
out there I don't want to make it sound
like there's some some people that are
really busy yeah I had a single mom
she's got two three kids she got two
three jobs yeah she doesn't you know
what she's listening this conversation
going yeah no kid yet okay wanted in
YouTube yes she's in the game 24/7 well
not choosing the game 20 because she
or she's sleeping 20 yeah she's keeping
it together yeah and when you say
they're busy but yeah they're two things
to that
yeah they're are busy people you know
how does Amanda go get those like the
single moms or the single dads they get
kinda like what I just said they are in
a situation they have no choice in right
after it yeah no choice maybe after
they're like oh I'm gonna get this done
they got their fam they're looking at
their kid they're looking at their
three-year-old kid that no dad's
three-year-old kid has nothing without
that mom getting on the grind and going
to the restaurant you know in working as
a waitress or whatever or she's working
her job whatever she's doing ever yes
putting it together knows exactly
Tuesday three weeks from now I at 4:46
she knows where she's going to be a she
knows exactly where me I mean on come on
you know compared to the average person
we don't know and then compared yeah but
you're not even like 100% sure which
should be doing in an hour because you
know cruising could interlude at any
time if you're going to that cruising is
a very ambiguous activity the but then
go to the other side of the spectrum of
busy people I mean they're busy because
they don't plan another special major
and yeah I'm so busy all the time
meanwhile no no productivity you know
yeah or very little limited yeah limited
true plan your day execute your plan
alright last little quote from this this
is Frederick the Great the Battle of
Colin in 1757 and there were some troops
that were read a couple different
versions again speaking of rabbit holes
you start going down these rabbit holes
I read two different versions of this
there was either troops that were
hesitating to attack or there were
troops that were actually retreating and
to these troops Frederick the Great said
dogs would you live forever
and another way that was translated was
you cursive Rascals would you live
forever and who they say mr. t saying
that to his own troop right right that
are leaving either either hesitating to
attack them or their order retreating
and he's saying dogs right yeah clutter
the barbarians and yeah not well on them
would you live forever know that what
you're looking for to live forever
yeah no you shouldn't be and you know I
I think that's a good way to wrap up
that book because like we said those two
quotes always do the business of the day
in the day so plan or you do and do what
you plan and dogs you curse it Rascals
would you live forever let me answer
that for you
no you won't and we're here talking
about a book we're talking about a book
today we talk about leadership and
that's awesome but you got to start by
leading yourself by doing what you say
you will do that's integrity personal
integrity when you say that you're going
to do something that they talked about
being straight today I talked about
personal integrity that starts with
yourself by doing what you actually say
you are going to do by not hesitating
and waiting got a lead yourself
so get moving don't wait
do what you plan and do it today because
you don't get to live forever
and the clock is ticking
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight and echo since we are not
hesitating right now if you could
without hesitation please explain to
people how they might be able to support
this podcast if they walk too sure of
course
because we don't want to live forever
that doesn't actually Conan the
Barbarian didn't say that what he would
go is he didn't say he doesn't say much
and Conan the Barbarian at a few lines
but not that much
he is girlfriend girl that ends up being
his girlfriend then she dies later but
whatever oh she said tell me hope when
they hesitate or when they're about to
do something nuts she says do you want
to live forever than they discharged our
okay well there you go come she takes
exactly yeah that's the exact usage
anyway speaking of not hesitating so
kettlebells let me talk about on it but
this kind of is relevant reminded me I
kind of mentioned it earlier before we
started recording so I hear good things
right kettlebells and I'm a little
familiar I'll incorporate them here and
there but you know I just hear more and
more so I'm like hey I'm gonna make this
big part of the you know the routine the
program yeah you do kettlebells
obviously yes yeah how much dumbbell
stuff did you like dumbbell
I actually don't use a lot right belt oh
yeah big dumbbell guy yeah like even
like bench right there I do it man oh
well on my bench like people will say
hey how much can you bench yeah I don't
know and not enough that's my answer
it's aa long time well anyway back to
accountable so starting kettlebells but
I got and you know you learn the test be
careful with kettlebells if you're doing
the kettlebells
yeah you know how they say yeah start
off like this I'd say with kettlebells
more so than it because when you throw a
Kelly that thing it's not a dumbbell is
like you grab a dumbbell it has a
perfect handle each side of the
dumbbells perfectly balanced
the same exact way BRAC kettlebell it
has a handle that's on the thing it'll
flip around it'll break you're right you
can break your hand or when you're
swinging them you know the one that you
go on all the terms vary but the one you
grab it with a to handle swing yeah
kettlebells the basic where the ball
sort between your legs
yep but I'm like swinging it and like
but what if this what if my balance was
off or I don't know whatever and the
kettlebell hit my shin a lot of pain bro
it can break your shin if you ever
should know even if you had like a 62
pounds
get over in break you should be careful
with that anyway so to make things
actually technically they're not what I
got the the on it ones the werewolf you
know and the champ and all that and you
think when you compare them to the
regular kettlebells they're the
kettlebells around right the regular
ones and so you'd think oh you know the
designer ones with the werewolf they
might be kind of awkward because they're
not like perfectly uniform what guess
what balanced when they make them yeah
so they're just as safe but so we're
going careful I'm I'm explaining the new
emergence of kettlebells in my workout
yeah and you like them I like them a lot
and the point is don't hesitate right
because you know how you know you could
do more kettlebells and be ambiguous
goal that's what it is no parameters but
I was like you know what today's a day
I'm going to do I'm gonna this is gonna
be the workout yeah so my work I was you
know you want numbers I'll keep you
numbers so what I did metcon kettlebells
the werewolf's so those are 62 pounds
each add to the double boom so it's like
a B I don't know if this is an actual
kettlebell official movement I think it
is you go it's like a kettlebell swing
two of them they're outside the hips
narrow stance up to clean okay you clean
it right and then threat and then press
it right and then back down Breslau
boom boom okay gross yes so I do five
reps and then five burpees walk in a
circle 35 seconds yeah all right five
reps again so I do that six times to
click eight minutes eight nine and ten
so same as well the maqam but with the
kettlebells and this ten of the squat
probably it's weird I used to do that
with a bar it's there's a lot of little
muscles in there that you gotta mix
kettlebells good is that the unstable
they're less stable than a barbell yeah
and they move awkwardly yeah so you have
to use more energy and more strength to
keep them under control yeah so it's
working some muscles that you're not
used to a most likely yeah and you're
it's it's interesting because you're
using like you can get into this kind of
it's not weird but it is slow of like
you know like when it swings down it's
not like oh it doesn't jerk you down it
will if you're not ready for it but if
you kind of know after you get used to
it it just flows this like this almost
no impact
yep kettlebells are good yeah so do that
anyway where would you get your cattle
goats from I get my kettle bells from on
it I only get the corn so actually
afterwards and I had a big girl's going
to post it online too but I think yeah
you are doing it was less about that at
that point you know but when I again the
werewolf forms so enjoy Rogen's on one
of the videos on there yeah he kind of
mentions is he's like I like this one
because it's like I think it's like the
gorilla or something like that
he's like it looks at you and it's like
it wants to says you know he says that
the gorilla looks like he wants to bite
your dick off that's what he said
something long this life but he has a
good point like those kettlebells when
you're like man I really don't want to
do this and then they're just looking at
you you know and you're like thank you
walk away you come back and you look at
it and it's still looking at you with
the same expression because it's you
know well cuz it's maybe an object
I'm saying it helps yeah you know cuz
you get into the workout you know yeah
you know especially like how you you're
like it's a challenge every time anyway
do that
all right on it support right I guess on
a dot-com slash choco 10% on it gets
kettlebells alpha brain strong bone yeah
krill oil big-time shroom tech yeah so
with the krill oil mine didn't come in
yet I slacked it with the wine didn't
come in yet and I'm kinda it's weird I'm
slowly started I'm not messed up I'm not
but I'm slowly starting to yeah I think
so huh actually want to go you want to
let it get out of your system completely
that's not good yeah then you got a
reincorporate into it yeah I think it
takes about six days yeah in my 50
corporate it took I think five when I
start to be like all you know I think it
comes in today for the less krill oil
the best krill oil straight up is from
on it so yeah on accomplished chuckle
10% off if you want that 10% off go
slash chocolate yeah
good way to support yourself podcast and
get after it more efficiently also if
you want to check out this book serve to
lead will have a post on the website it
takes you to Amazon grab these books
from there you click through the website
that supports podcast really good we'll
be buying these books in eBook we didn't
lose Shashi last week no we did book of
five rings last week musashi the novel
will be covered in podcast 100 yeah if
you are we are going to talk about the
whole book it's a novel so it's going to
be spoilers so if you want to listen to
that podcast you got to read that book
now it's a thousand pages long it's
freaking long yes so get the book now so
that you can get the satisfaction of the
book because it has the most epic ending
it's one of the most epic endings of any
books yeah and it's on the docket
podcast.com website books drop podcast
books they're all on there
also the one
you mentioned it today one called mind
games the book that I read oh you put
that on there didn't yet
the author is Michael Powell here's the
thing it's not like it's not like a
typical book where it's like talks about
anger management it's not that it's it's
literally like there's little games like
mind brain exercises in there you know
it's just everything and they're really
short chapters they're just little
things and that one chapter happened to
be about dealing with anger anyway
Michael Powell is the author unknown
looking I'll put it on there though
legit yeah so yeah anyway Amazon click
through basically you click through
there boom takes an Amazon it's a little
support thing you know small action big
reaction or if you do other shopping on
there duct tape duct tape if you will so
yeah any shopping really but you know
these books that's a good that's a real
relevant one I think that people um you
know they do want to take grab these
books and boom they're on their offer
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already iTunes stitcher google
play whichever one you prefer
I think iTunes is the most popular but I
see significant references to Google
Play in general society you know also a
lot of times that your stitcher yeah you
know how like a lot of them people they
don't want to go mainstream you know oh
yeah it's like like they're like you
keep it old-school hair on your ground
yeah you know it makes sense you know
what's the old saying don't go with the
herd or path let's travel you know one
of the all of the same same deal same
deal so I get it google play up but good
news is were on all of them rather so go
choose your your Avenue also YouTube
subscribe to our YouTube channel so we
do have you YouTube channel talk about
every week but it not only does it have
the video version of this podcast has
excerpts and deluxe excerpts one of
those excerpts that you have enhanced
will just say enhance step excerpts also
you know what man I have this other idea
you know what I'm going to do I want to
make little
we'll just say other little videos to
doesn't mean to get bad add value sort
of speaking like that well the video is
a very compelling form of interaction
with people yeah like that's why that's
why YouTube I think YouTube is like the
most searched - website bigger than it's
more search than Google maybe I'm wrong
but it's up there if it's not number one
it's number two you know if you want to
learn something people immediately yes
search YouTube
yes that's what and guess what remember
the other day we talked about YouTube
red yeah I got YouTube red I'll buy
because the ad ads is one thing but also
because you can listen to music without
it being on the screen it plays in the
background like iTunes that is that the
mainly yeah
now I can get any album that of a lot of
music a lot of music that I listen to
isn't on iTunes because it's old-school
it's hardcore it's Underground like
literally not on there yeah but the
YouTube videos up there crazy how do you
have video beyond there from some random
hardcore band yeah from New York upstate
New York and there one album that they
made their one EP 5 songs long that came
out in 1987 it'll be on YouTube it's not
anywhere near iTunes yeah it's on it you
can play it which is awesome yeah makes
sense I guess they YouTube bread
sometimes they'll put or not something
all the time really to read now no
because the main selling point ROM is at
the album's without tracks - yeah you
like albums with tracks as you're out
without tracks well typically I don't
listen to YouTube for the music
situation where I go - you have red
you'll change that yeah maybe
I mean red they push it with hey no ads
and then I'm like cool no as but man I'm
not that quick to jump on the no ads
thing I there's been plenty time so a
lot of times with movies but the ads
that play I'll like it'll be for me
directly for me like dang was added
along me in a way sometimes
yeah ultimate YouTube person that'll
make it quick for next video I'm going
to enjoy the advertisement I get the Tai
Lopez ads a lot you know that is right
Tai Lopez she's um she's a super smart
guy he's actually one of the reasons why
like I started reading a lot like one of
the reasons and so smart guy played his
answer all over YouTube right but I know
it's my fault because it's relevant to
what I watch apparently how they do that
so it's my fault but that's those lads I
get times this should you go to college
yeah you know what I'm talking about
anyway um yeah so yeah subscribe to our
YouTube you know got some subscribers on
there some good feedback you know I'm
gonna keep posting videos it does help
that people will say echo post videos in
addition to just use requesting peer
pressure like that yeah um so yeah
subscribe to e to does get a uh also
chakra is a store called Yahoo store JA
coaster calm on there we have t-shirts
if you wear t-shirts you know check them
out um if you're interested in anything
on there get something I'm not saying to
buy so I'm not saying hey price go to
drop cool store come and buy a t-shirt
I'm not saying that saying go to jockle
store calm there's some shirts on there
some hoodies on there rash guards
patches some women's stuff some tank
tops and whatnot travel mugs hats coming
soon anyway check them out if you like
hats coming soon before yes I've been
impressed by your turn times on that it
just depends on what you think soon well
you say soon to me I that made me mean
every day's okay so I grew up in Kauai
perhaps okay we're in from nautical now
I'm not saying that far in town I'm not
saying that is but that's not what I'm
playing right now okay so quiet in OMA
on koi
you know why so on the end of a mile
road is a I don't know what it is to
church a religious center or something
and it says on the top it says Jesus
coming soon and that went up when I was
I think seven years old so
is a relative term very relative yes
it's a sliding scale for sure let me say
what hats
I hope get here before the return of
Jesus
yeah if that's the goal for sure we can
make that happen to be awesome
alright cuz we got it summertime you
know now right now summertime we need
hats to wear in the Sun all right to
block the Sun yes that's what have to do
yeah gotcha
so yeah there it is Jocko store calm if
you see something on there that you like
you recognize the layers grab something
support here's a little thing Jocko
designed a shirt designed specifically
100% too by the way by Jocko I even
tried to put my little pinky in there
and I'm input yes right up tonight I'm
like bro do you know who manages that
shirt yet
that shit's not up it's being printed
but you know we went with it and 100%
jock was designed 100% not really
approved by me
I mean it's approved but like I tried to
like make my little considerations my
little alterations and observations and
you know I was watching out for the
alterations
I was worried about it my creative my
leery overcame them well totally
overcame them yeah I don't mean oh right
we're making this shirt and that's a
direct order exactly would happen yes
now you're yeah you finessed it for sure
but at the end of the day I looked up
and I was like dang my input on you know
the store that you know I think I feel
like I'm the manager of the store yeah
apparently I'm wrong but that's cool so
anyway new shirt
as a result designed by choco chuckle
Starcom that's a good also psychological
warfare if you know what that is it's an
album with tracks of chocolate voice
saying and telling helping that's what
it's doing it's helping
people myself included by the way
through moments of weakness if they
arrive arise
alright then right yeah so yes you're
having trouble or one day if you want an
alarm clock of me which people asked me
for yeah just get psychological warfare
and set it as your alone yeah that's it
that's why we made it because everyone
was asking for that so there you have it
you don't need to you don't need it
we're not going to make a ringtone I
don't think yeah well tell ya
technically you just said it as their
you just said it as a ringtone or you're
right yeah it's yeah and it works really
good especially that well it depends on
your weakness right or what kind of
person you are so you know me if you say
echo wake up at 4:30 for one year every
morning one year there's going to be a
day or two where it's going to be harder
than you know then another day so put on
the trash what time do you wake up
that's classified so if you have
problems I guess are like we reckon noon
I woke up at noon on Saturday okay so on
a lion time hit away by noon how could
you even do that
no I didn't mean to it I it was it's a
long story but yes my wife was like hey
it was good for you to join us or nice
dude nice of you to join us you know
that wife is ragging on you first yeah
until noon Wow credit to her she was
just like I got to here to take care of
the record sprawled out straight-up
mcclure queen-size bed getting after
okay not to make a change nonetheless
back to psychological warfare if you
have you know if you're on a cool diet
you're eating is clean boom you get that
temptation one day at work the donuts
you don't like bring the donors right we
talk about these all the time yeah
people just do that to Kathy don't
Gracie here on our Wyatt
Harlan he talks about um like how you go
to a restaurant and they're like also
cute the kids here some you know here's
a cupcake for the ghetto cute right and
people like overlook how rude in uh it's
like how much of a violation that is
yeah rat poison you can feed them while
you're at it
Hey look look how cute your kids are
kids let me give them something super
unhealthy violation anyway
that's what happens when people bring
Donuts for work and think I'm going to
do this for the office not that I frown
upon that I'm just saying put it into
perspective nonetheless if someone does
that while you're at work
boom you got a track for that to put it
on real quick then your buds you know so
it's for you sugar-coated lashes
recruited life directly into here anyway
it's called psychological warfare look
at it on or look for it on iTunes
chocolate Google Play Google Play mm
music all that stuff good stuff wherever
the mp3s are being distributed all right
also on Amazon you can get jock a white
P and here's a little Van Slyke purchase
review again this means that the person
is verified yeah it's a percent so
here's the review as a tea guy I am
somewhat picky so I ordered some
chocolate tea I'm pretty sure the box
was growling when I opened it that's a
verified reviewed up some tea and poured
it over ice after which I went onto my
bike for training ride I was pulled over
twice I explained that I consumed some
jock white tea before I left the officer
just nodded in said get after it
the next officer was not so forgiving
and gave me a ticket for speed limit so
in summary this to you can get pretty
pricey if you don't mind speeding
tickets while you're riding a bike so
that's just another thing to be careful
of if drink jakka white tea and then you
get on a bike you've got to watch out
that you don't get speeding tickets
because you're going to go a little
faster than the speed limit
that's the choco light tea also on
Amazon you can get wolf way to warrior
kid and this this review here way the
warrior kid also verified purchase
review from Amazon this is the book I
wish I'd read when I was a kid and
that's the same thing I say all the time
I work in schools and I've already
bought a spare copy to lend out to my
students I've also read it twice myself
though I'm 39 year old man side note my
pull-ups have also improved so I'm
telling you it's a kids book sure that's
what everyone says that's you know what
it's
it kind of looks like this lesson to
national uncle Jake that we all need so
we're the warrior kid you can pick that
one up
also discipline equals freedom Field
Manual you know what this book is about
it's about getting after it mentally and
physically simple straightforward
so if you want to get after it get the
discipline equals freedom field manual
not a lot of fluff in there I'm going to
tell you that right now not a lot of
fluff straight forward of course we got
the book extreme ownership it's the book
we refer back to a bunch on here combat
leadership for your life for your
business for your school for your family
for you own it and for your business or
your team you can get a special on front
leadership manage the consulting to help
bring leadership at your team to the
next level that is Lafe babban who wrote
extreme ownership with me that is JP
Danelle that is Dave Burke both those
guys have been on the podcast to work
both with those both those guys
extensively in the battle Ramadi and
myself also a Daschle on front so that's
what we do we go into companies and we
help you with your leadership info at a
salon.com
if you're interested also the muster in
Austin Texas to live 13th and 14th Omni
Barton Creek Resort I think this might
be sold out by the time this airs it's a
venue that's only 300 seats we've sold
most of them if you don't get a ticket
in time to that check extreme ownership
calm see if you can still get a ticket
for that one and if you don't get a
ticket in time for that one that's okay
come to San Diego September 14th and
15th for muster 0 0 for that one is also
at the Omni Hotel but the one in San
Diego lots of folks are coming back to
that
lots of people that went to the first
muster in San Diego are coming back for
another go it's going to be awesome we
will see you there
and in the meantime if you want to talk
to us we are actually upon the interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram and we're going
to see that one on the face walking echo
is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing and thanks to everyone from
listening to the podcast but don't just
listen go out wake up earlier work out
harder read more make yourself better a
better soldier a better sailor better
Airmen or a better marine a better
police officer a better firefighter a
better paramedic make yourself a better
engineer or janitor or waitress or
waiter or lawyer or doctor or car
mechanic or builder make yourself a
better person a better leader every day
and as Charlie May said on July 1st 1916
before he went over the top into the
raging hell that was the Battle of the
Somme he said it is a glorious morning
and it certainly is
all of them are every morning is
glorious
so get out there and get after it and
until next time this is echo and Jocko
out